ブッダンサラナンガッチャーニ
ダンマンサラナンガッチャーニ
サンガムサラナンガッチャーニ
ブッダンサラナンガッチャーニ
ダンマン  では よろしくお願いします
これから今日のテーマについてお話をします
今日のテーマはむさぼらない
というテーマになります
提案なさった側がね 怒らないということをね
喋りましたからね むさぼらないことも必要でしょうと
とは言ってもね なかなかこのむさぼりについてはちょっと喋りにくいところがいっぱいあります
怒らないテーマほど面白くはないと思いますし
まああんまり面白く喋るぐらいのまあ明るい状態でいられる時でもありませんので
もう今はね ということで
すごくつまらないかもしれませんだけど
淡々と理論だけ申し上げます
はい  このむさぼらないことについて
まず理論だけ覚えておいてください
もう仏教っていうのは
まあ理論的にシステムがわかっちゃえば
この智慧でなんとかなるぞという立場ですから
あんまりギャーギャーいろんなことを言って人に迷惑をかけるということはまずないんです
心さえ強ければ 心さえ明るくあれば
物事を判断できれば もう何でもできますよというもう立場ですからね
というわけで まず命って何でしょうかと
そのそのテーマにおいて
ちょっと定義の説明は変わりますけどね
命 あるいは生きるとは
肉体と心の合同作業ですね
肉体は肉体でいろいろシステムができて起動しているし
これ心というものがあって
心もそれなりにいろいろ仕事をしているし
その 2つが一緒になって活動をしているんですね
それが命ということになるんです
それから まあちょっと分けて考えますね
肉体の場合はね 肉体は常に変化して壊れていくのです
物質っていうのはずっと変化して
変化して変化して まあ壊れて壊れて壊れて壊れて壊れていくんです
対し修復処理などしなくてはいけません
だから体がすーっと壊れているならば
すーっと我々は処理しなくちゃいけないんです
私たちには体が成長する
衰えていくという 2つの概念があります
一般社会では あの人は今成長しているとかね
あの人は衰えているとかって
2つの単語がありますけど
まとめると 一定のスピードで変化していくことになります
あの 2つの単語はそんな意味がないんです
すーっと体が一定のスピードで変化して壊れて壊れていくんです
子供だから少年だから老年だからって別に差がないんです
同じスピードで 壊れてゆく肉体に新たな物質を入れるんです
そんなに難しいことじゃないんですからね
体が壊れていくと 我々は新たな物質を取り入れるんです
まず壊れる量よりたくさん物質を入れる
人間が何するのかと 最初は壊れる量と気にしないで結構入れちゃいます
大量に 余分な物質の使用使用している間
成長していると思い 壊れる側面を無視されるんです
そこで体に物質壊れると
壊れた分よりもたくさん入れちゃうと体が全部使っちゃう
入れたもの 例えば数字で冗談で言うならば
40ぐらい壊れたんだけど
60 70 ぐらい入れちゃったんですね
入れちゃったらもう全部使っちゃったら
30 ぐらい成長してるということになっちゃうんです
体が大きくなったっていうことになるんです
我々成長っていうのはそんなもんなんですね
体が破壊している量よりもたくさん物質を入れる
この入れた物質を受け取っちゃうんですね
体が ある時壊れる量と同じ量の物質を使用
いくら入れてもある時期になると壊れたところ
四十壊れたら四十だけいただいて
残りは長いことにするんですね
これで成長が止まっていると言うんです
みんな病気になるのはその時なんですね
余分に入れたものはもう物質だから腐るんだから溜まるんだから
で 壊れたところは全部いただきます
だから別にもう成長するっていうこともないし
衰えるってこともなくなっちゃうんですね
ある時 壊れる量より少ない量を使用するんです
ある時間になると 体がある程度で壊れるんだけど
新たに物質入れたら使いますけど
壊れる量より少ない量を使うんですね
四十壊れたらもう八十入れてるんだけど
三十しか使わないんですね
そうなってくると 体の状況がどんどん衰えていくんです
で 我々人間のね 少中老というこの三段階ありますから
その段階は俗世間でそう言うんだけど
仏教の真理の立場から見れば同じスピードで壊れているだけなんですね
しかし 体がこの修復作業にとっては
なんかちょっと能力は
最初は結構修復能力あるんだけど
この修復能力はどんどん減っていくんです
減っていって だいたい死にかけていると
もう全部ストップするんですね
私は長い間飼っていたワンちゃんがね
この四日 五日前亡くなりましたけど
連絡があって もう全くも何も食べないんだと
で 熱があったり 医者に見せても
まあまあ 栄養剤注射したりしたっても
ところで薬とか何とか何とか強引に口に入れても
もう吐き出すんだと だから物質入れることはもうワンちゃんはストップしちゃったんですね
それで二日 三日でもう亡くなってしまったんですね
同じことは人間にも起こります
すごい世界一栄養剤やりますよと言っても
あの代謝能力は消えたらもうどうしようもないんですね
徐々衰えているということになるんですね
それで生きるっていうことはどういう
これ 命のことなんですね
命っていうのは何かある工場みたいんですよ
今 物質 体のことだけ喋ってますよ
それから心のことも説明します
体自体も何か一つ工場みたいで
もう工場というか 何か機械みたいなものでずっと修復しなくちゃいけないし
しかしどんどんどんどんもう劣化して使えなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで生きるということは
肉体は地水火風でできているとする場合
まあちょっと仏教専門用語に入ります
物質 物質といっても 現代世界で言ってる物質は仏教で考えていないんです
で やばいしね そんなこと考えたらね
まあウランとかあれやこれやとかっていうのは
仏教は地水火風という四つの元素でできているんだというね
物質よりも素粒子というか
根本的なエネルギーのところで発見しているんですね
お釈迦様は実験研究しないんだから
瞑想で 体で 心で直視するものだから
心がエネルギーしか認識しないしね
だから 土やら建物よりも
そこから伝わってくるエネルギーを認識して
そこが物質ということにしているんです
はい そういうことだから
仏教では地水火風という ４つの物質
素粒子 あるいはエネルギーでできているというんですね
体の体の地水火風は出ていくたびに新たな地水火風を入れることになるんですね
で なんで地水火風とエネルギーにしたのかというと
エネルギーといったら止まるものじゃないんです
必ずしも移動があって
一箇所にいることはできないんですね
変化しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから地水火風とは４種類のエネルギーなんですね
あの現代的な物質で考えると
あるということになっちゃうんです
で 変わらない あるんだぞと
それは仏教でないんですね
あるということは言えませんよと
もうずっと変化するんだと
ですから 物質はもうエネルギーで語っていて
で エネルギーだから体は止まれないんですね
ずっとエネルギーが出ていくんです
出ていくと 新たなエネルギーを入れなくちゃいかないんです
物の変化が止まらないので
体を維持する作業にも休みがないんです
だから 何一つも世の中で止まらないでしょ
地球の自転公転にしようか
太陽が燃えることにしようが
宇宙の変化であろうか
一瞬とも止まることないんですね
ずっと変化しているんですね
それでこの肉体も一瞬とも止まることなく変化しているんですね
ということは 我々はすーっと修復しなくちゃいかないんです
休みがないんです 休みのないこの作業に生きているというんです
そこで私たちは休みないんです
ずっと体に手を入れなくちゃいけないんです
修復しなくちゃいけないんです
寝ても休めないんです
ずっと体をもう修復しているんです
寝ていても起きていても
大変なことなんですよ
一秒でもちょっと休めようと思ってもできないんです
そういうことで 瞬間たりとも休みなく
我々は生きるということをしているんです
生きるっていうことはどういうことかというと
大したことじゃないんです
壊れる地水火風の代わりに新しい地水火風を入れているだけ
面白い ありがたい 尊い
快楽と言える状態ではないんです
生きていることはなんて面白いですかとかね
なんて楽しいでしょうかとかね
なんて命って尊いやと
そんなことは言えた場合じゃないんです
ちゃんと見るとどうってことないんです
本当はつまらないんです
結構おっかないんですね
ちょっとも休みがないんだから
ほんのちょっとも あの
お釈迦様とこの大阿羅漢の方々は
この瞑想の達人の中の達人だから
ものすごい瞑想を成長させて
あえて強力な力で止めることはします
その時は地水火風はカチッと止まるんです
肉体の これはもう科学的に
現代人の知識ではどういうことかと理解全くできないと思います
体の動きは完全に止まるんです
ということは 医学的に言えば死んでいることになります
しかし 細胞の動きまで
原子の動きまで止まったらどう言えばいいんですかね
我々は死んでいると思って
我々は原子の動きが止まったことは一度たりとも経験したことないでしょう
原子やら様々な素粒子やら止まりましたとはありえないんですね
これ 心のパワーで止めるんです
だから それは当時の人々にはね
まあ現代人にもわからないと
当然 当時の人々には全くわからないんですから
もうちょっと俗っぽく
田舎の人々にわかるようによく語ってます
このこの禅定に入った人が呼吸もしないし
心臓も動かないんだけど
死んではいないんだと
それ誰かが火をつけて死んでるんだからって言って
火をつけて焼いても焼けませんよと
焼けませんでしょ だって原子まで止まってるんだから
どんな火を回りつけてもね
薪を そういうケースも物語とエピソードとして
なんとかなんとか 阿羅漢がね
禅定に入っていて 森の中でね
もうみんななんか大変なことになって
この人死んでるんだって言って
薪を持ってきて燃やしちゃったと
2日間ぐらい薪を回してから出て行ったんですけどね
その阿羅漢はまあ禅定に決まった時間が終わったら
何のこともなく立ち上がって出て行ったと
で そんなこと言ったら宗教のね
インチキ話やと思うでしょうし
まあ私にも今はそんな瞑想禅定に入れる人がいませんだからね
もうなんてことも言えませんだけど
一応まあテキストでは理論的にはそういう状態
これは特別な心のパワーを使って物質を一時停止させるんです
で それ以外はね 休むなく物質は変化しているんです
ですから この 大変面白くないんです
生きるっていうこと はい
次 心の関わりについて
物質に感覚があることは生きていることですね
この物質だけじゃないんですね
この肉体は感じるんですね
反応するんですね 一個一個の細胞は
何らかの反応するんです
細胞それぞれ違いますから
反応の仕方が変わってるんですけど
とにかく反応はするんです
他のものに これが心ということなんです
いわゆる感覚があることなんですね
物質が壊れることは心が感じるんです
そこでこの物質の中で感覚があるんだから
物質が壊れると感覚でわかるんですね
壊れたと ちょっと減ったと
苦しいと感覚が変わるんです
そうすると あの感覚が苦しいということに変わっちゃうんです
だって お腹が空いたら苦しいでしょ
楽しいわけないでしょ
喉が渇いたら苦しいでしょ
楽しいわけじゃないんです
だからまあ 苦しいって感覚が生まれてくるんです
で 物質を入れる意欲が起こるんです
それで物質を入れなくちゃいけないということになるんです
これが心がやっているんです
心がないとご飯食べません
水も飲みません 喋ったりもしません
歩いたり運動したりしません
だからやっていることは何でもかんでも心がやっている
まぶた閉じることさえも苦しみでやっているんです
まぶたを閉じないように
セロハンテープででも貼っておいてみてください
どうなるのかと 相当苦しくなるんです
だからその苦しみは心が感じて
まぶたはパチパチパチパチで飛ばして
もう閉じたり開けたり
閉じたり開けたりしてくれます
だから私たちはもういろんなことをするのは苦しみがあるんだからなんですよ
例えば唇の方がちょっと乾いてしまっちゃって
別に大した苦しみがないんだけど
なんか普通よりはちょっと気分が良くないんです
ね それで時々ね 何かクリーム塗ったりしますね
例えば 皮膚がちょっと乾いちゃって
なんか痒みような感じが出てきますね
あんまり気分がいいわけじゃないんです
では 足にクリーム入れておこうということになっちゃうんです
だから 全ての生きる行為は苦という感覚で起きるんです
髪を洗うことであろうが
髪型はちょっといろいろおしゃれしようかとかね
何でもかんでも苦という感覚が作るんだ
例えば 鏡で顔 髪の毛見たところで
なんてかっこ悪いかと
と思っちゃうんです 鏡で自分見えるわけでもないんだけど
全く変なものを見えてますけどね
私たちは自分だと思っていて
これはかっこ悪いと では
なんとかこれ染めなくちゃとかね
もうもう金髪にしなくちゃとかね
パーマかけなくちゃとかいろいろ思っちゃうんです
だからこの苦がやってます
全部 冷静に必要な物質を入れればいいのに
そこで苦しみが生まれる
どうしようもないんです
それだったら これぐらい量が減ったんだから
これぐらい量を入れましょうと冷静にクールでやればいいんです
この動きに気づかない生命は
物質を入れなくてはという感情を引き起こすんです
ここで感情が起こるんです
あ ご飯食べなくてはとかね
あ 水を飲まなくてはとか
寝なくちゃとかね あ 大変だ
もう運動しなくてはとか
服を着なくちゃとかね
ベースに冷静でやればいいんですよね
これ 冷静でクールでできないんです
今の皆さんはもう同じことなの
普通仕事をする時でも
家のことをする時でも
どうも感情が割り込んでくるんですね
大変だ これやらなくちゃとかね
これが欲むさぼりの始まりです
もう欲むさぼりがもう生まれたんです
本当は余計なことなんです
お腹が空いたら単純にご飯を食べればいいのに
そこで感情が割り込んじゃうんです
その感情が欲むさぼりというんです
これはどんな生命にもあります
それで終わらない欲というものになるんです
体が壊れることは休みなく起こる
物質の入れ替えに欲の感情が起きたならば
それも終わりなく続くんです
体が壊れることに終わりがないでしょ
あ 入れなくては入れなくてはという感情にも終わりがなくなっちゃうんです
それでスーッと生命が欲の感情で生きる羽目になるんです
感情とは激しくなったり
弱くなったりします 別に理屈ないでしょ
感情に もうわかるでしょ？別に喉が渇いたら何か水が水飲めばいいだけのことで
ああ 水飲めなくちゃ飲まなくてはと思っちゃうと
何の理屈もないでしょうに
ただのアホだけなんですね
そんな興奮しなくてもいいでしょうに
そんなに緊張感感じなくてもいいでしょうに
だから理論理性で関係なく感情が生まれる
この感情になってくると
やっぱり強弱がありまして
激しい感情があって まあそれほど感じない程度の微妙な感情があったり
いろいろですね その感情の波によって
欲のそれによって様々な変化するんです
だから欲の長い長いリスト
仏典にありますけど 今日は紹介しませんが
あまりにもありすぎですからね
例えば嫉妬するはものすごい
もう右も左もわからないぐらい欲が出てくるわ
いろいろあります あるいは欲があって
まあいいやというふうに諦めるぐらいの弱い程度の感情もあるし
例えばなんかお腹が空いてますけど
まあご飯食べなくちゃいけないんですけど
まあいいや 今忙しいんだから後で食べますとかね
まあ食べないことにしますとか
何のことなくパスする場合もあります
その場合は感情がすごく弱い
どうしても食べなくちゃっていうことになっちゃうと
遅刻 たとえ仕事に学校に遅刻してでも食べちゃうんです
そのように その都度その都度
この欲の感情が強烈になったり
薄くなったりする 欲の感情がやっぱり強烈になったところで
とても危険なんです 例えば
あまりにもお腹が空いちゃって
もう我慢できなくなった
できなくなかったところで
強盗までして食べる可能性ありますよ
その時は感情はかなり強くなっているんです
例えば 金が欲しいという欲があったら
普通の人は仕事するんですね
しかし 理性がなくて金が欲しいだけになってくると
コンビニに包丁を持って行くんです
何としてでも手に入れたいと思ったところで
人を殺しまでするんです
殺して財布を奪ったりして
財布を開けてみたら 2万しかなかったということもありますね
日本で起きたケースですからね
だからそれも欲でしょうに
これ 欲が感情だからいろいろ波を打っちゃうんですね
どうしても基本的にあるんだから
もう誰も安心ということは言えません
必ずもうというか なんか原因が揃ったところで
ガッともう津波と同じです
あ 津波は起きませんよとはもうわからないでしょうに
海がある限り 海がある限り
海の中のほどで地震が起きたらもう津波になるんです
それはもうこんな程度やとかね
ちょこっとちょこっと
100年ぐらいのデータを調べて
津波ってどんな程度やとは決めることもね
とんでもないアホらしい態度なんですね
はい 今回の津波がもう地球で起こるべき一番大きい津波だと決定できますかね
できんでしょうに もっとひどい津波も起こる可能性あります
だからなぜかというと
このいつでもこの原因があるんだからね
地球が動いているし 地球のプレートも動いているし
これはもう溶岩と液体の上にあるしね
その上 地球の 4分の3海でしょうし
まあ知ったことじゃないんです
そんな感じで この生きるものに欲がある限りは
まあどんな波を起こすかっていうことはかなりわからないということになります
人は欲に支配される時も
欲に気づかない時もあります
欲に支配されて奴隷になって
欲のために何でもやるぞという時もあるし
まあ別にという感じで欲があるんだけど
落ち着いている場合もあります
仏教 物質を入れるとは体の維持管理を意味します
はい 今までずっと物質を入れると言っても
その意味は忘れちまいました
物質を入れるということは
体の維持管理のことなんです
だから 食べることは歩くこと
もう顔を洗うこと，もう服を着ることなどなど
寝ること お風呂に入ること
全部もう体の維持管理でしょ
それ全て仏教から見れば
治水化風の入れ替えなんです
冬とか寒い時はお風呂に入る
何のことなく あー気分がいいと暖かいと
なんのことない 熱を入れてるだけ
熱が出ていっちゃう 出ていくんだからね
その分入れると もう気分がいいというふうに言うんですね
はい はい 次 心の変化 体を支配して体に依存して行動するが
その心も無常で変化するんです
はい この肉体は単純な物体で
感覚が入って全部やっているんです
感覚があるんだから生きているんです
食べたいと思うんです
寝たいと思うんです 感覚があるんだから
という感覚自体もろくなものじゃないんです
これは体を支配していて偉そうな態度をとってますけど
自分も無常なんです 体に依存しているし
心が依存して体を支配するんです
だから微妙に微妙にうまくいかないんです
依存するということは
あなたがなければ何もできないという意味でしょう
と言いながら あんたこうしなさい
ああしなさいと言うんですね
これはちょっとぶつかるんですよ
例えば 人間の関係では
あなたがなかったら私はどうにもならんよというふうに人に全面的に依存すると
その人を言う通りにするんです
相手が言う通りにするんです
人に依存して その人に命令することになっちゃうと
結構トラブっちゃうんです
だから我々の人生では
それは毎日の経験なんです
心がやりたいことは山ほどあるんだけど
なかなか体が応じていかないんですね
応じようとすると体が壊れるんです
体が壊れると 逆に心はまた心配して怖くなるんです
時々あまりも成績出しちゃって
スポーツマンとかね 一生懸命いろいろ訓練して
それで体が壊れたり また復活できない状態になったり
ずっとスポーツ世界にさようならしなくちゃいけない羽目にもなりますね
それはあまりにも心が意欲を出しちゃって
頑張れ頑張れと言うんだから
そんなこと言ったって
もう肉体にはできるわけないんですね
だから無理をやっちゃうんです
無理やったところで体が壊れるんで
壊れたら 私は有名なスポーツ人で
もう結構儲かるはずでしたけど
今何にもできなくて車椅子になっちゃったと
すっごく落ち込まなくちゃいけないんです
はい それっていうのは体と心の関係でよく起こること
誰にでも起こることなんです
はい それで偉そうに支配する心も結局は無常なんです
心が滅するたびに新たな心が起こるんです
で 心の場合は物質と法則が違うんです
滅せちゃうと すぐ新たな心が生まれるんです
仏教の物質論では物質も同じ法則やと言いますけどね
現代思考ではちょっと別
まあ別な考えですけど
それで心が無常だからなくなる
なくなったら新しい心が生まれるんです
隙間がないんです なくなったら生まれる
なくなったら生まれる
隙間がなく 心が生まれて生まれて生まれていくんです
これにもエネルギーが必要ですよに
単純に生まれるわけじゃないんです
心に刺激 いわゆる対象が必要なんです
心っていうのは認識する働きです
だから感覚と言えばわかりやすいんですね
感覚は認識するんですからね
感じるんだからね だから感じるために感じるものが必要なんです
何か感じるものがあったら心が生まれるんです
だから心はもう対象に依存しているんです
対象といったらわからない方々は刺激というふうにしてください
対象がないと心は生まれません
結構やばいことになりますよ
心が消えたらもう命も終わりですよ
はい それで説明 眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つのチャネルで絶えず刺激を受けているんです
大丈夫です 対象は消えません
チャネル 6つもあります
対象が流れ込む 流れ込む
流し込む あの原始郎と違います
もう 6つのチャネルからもう情報が流れています
ありすぎぐらい で 心に刺激して変化することは簡単にできます
だから体には維持管理することはそう簡単じゃないんです
心にとってはもう心配することないんです
嫌になるほど刺激があるんです
だから死んでも死んでもまた生まれるんです
はい 心の変化と欲 眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つのチャネルに色声香味触法という 6種類の対象が流れるんです
で わからない方々はシンプルで理解してください
目に見えるものが限りなく流れ込んでいるんですね
耳に音が限りなく流れ流れているんですね
鼻とか まあそんなもんなんですね
頭にはいろんなアイディアが
概念が限りなく流れるんですから
触れるんだから もういくらでもあります
触れることで心に絶えず回転することができます
この仏教専門用語を使った方がスマートでまとめて語れます
私は一応現代語に入れますけど
こういう極限に難しいところは現代語ではうまくいかないんです
ですから 専門用語を使うしかないんです
これは明確に心が 6つのチャネルで認識するんだよっていうことは
現代的には全然考えたこともないんです
生き続けるために対象に依存しなくてはいけません
それで我々は生き続けるために
この 6つのチャネルから流れ込んでくる情報に依存しなくてはいけないんです
それで色声香味触法に対して執着
欲が起こるんです これまた余計なんです
だって腐るほど情報があるんだから
依存する必要ないでしょうに
嫌ででも認識生まれるんだから
しかし心がこいつらに依存しなくちゃ
俺には立場がないと知ってるんだから
そこで対象 大事にするんです
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
味わえるもの 体に触れるもの
考えるものを大事にしちゃうんです
これが愛着というんです
これが欲なんです これまた余計いらんことやっているんです
対象対象が触れたら認識が起こることは法則なので
対象に触れたら認識が生まれる
こんなのは法則 例えばマッチをね
あのボックスの外の薬
なんとかありますね そちらに消すったら振ったらもう火が出ますよ
別にお願いします 火が出てくださいとかね
どうでもいいことでしょうに
そんなのは マッチを擦ってやっちゃえばそれで終わりですから
出ますから そのように感覚器官があって
対象が触れたらもう認識が生まれてるんです
あのマッチと同じです
だからマッチの火が出てほしいとかね
なんてありがたいとかね
バカバカらしいんです
なのに我々の体の中で
生命の中で こんなアホなことを起きているんです
色声香味触法という対象に愛着するんです
執着するんです 大事にするんです
これが心に起こる欲なんです
これもまたキリ限りなく続け続けちゃうんです
本当に余計なことなんです
欲が起きたこと自体もバカバカらしくて
何するのかというぐらいもうアホなことなんです
が 私たちはこのブッダがこんな法則を語らない限りは
こんな法則やと知らないんです
だから欲がどうしても心は汚してるんです
で 法則なので あえて欲が起きなくてもいいのに
無知なので絶えず欲の感情が起きてしまうんです
こんなことになります
はい これで欲はどのように生まれるのかっていうところはまあ理解していただければすごいありがたいことなんですけど
はい それでまとめなんですけど
ということで なんかもう無始なる過去から我々に欲があったことわかるでしょう
まあ仏教は輪廻転生の話ですから
無始なる過去からもう生まれ死んで生まれ死んできたんだからね
だったら生まれていたならば
もう欲があるんです じゃあ輪廻は知らないことにしましょう
じゃあ今世で生をできた瞬間からも欲があるんです
本来生命は それに因果法則に気づかないので
本能として欲が現れることは避けられません
普通 因果法則にはなかなか気づかないんです
これすごい あの普通の心の認識能力で発見することは難しいんです
だから誰も因果法則を知らないってことになるんです
ということは 生命たるものには本能として欲があるんです
欲が悪い 余計いらないと言い
また間違いですけど 言っても理解できません
この漢字ではなくて ただいいなんです
ひらがなの 欲によって悩み
苦しみが悩み 苦しみ 悲しみなどの様々な苦が起きると
心が汚れてさらに不幸になると言われても納得できません
ね 正直なところ 欲は生きている人にとっては大事な欠かせない感情で
幸福楽しみを与えてく与えるものだと思っているんです
人間みんなそう思ってるんです
他の生物を思っているんです
欲って余計やと言っても
何が余計かと 必要でしょうと反発するんです
日本に書かれてる仏教学者の本でも
欲なんかは足すことは不可能ですと偉そうなことを書くんです
だからまあ私は別に冷静で読みますけど
まあ仏教学者が仏教を理解しないのは当たり前のことだから
まあそれはその通りやと
しかし 仏教を理解すると
そういうことになります
あれは余計なんです 余計な迷惑なんです
はい 次 欲になるものという
何が欲を引き起こすのかというね
欲を作る対象をカーマワットといいます
パーリ語でカーマワットという
カーマは欲って意味なんですね
ワットっていうのはオブジェクト
対象ですね 目に入る色
耳に入る音などの 5つです
まあ 5つ言ってますね
目に入るもの 耳に入るもの
鼻に入るもの いわゆる香りですね
舌に入るもの 味 それから体に触れるもの
その 5つです それは欲の対象
色声香味触に対する欲
愛着 執着が仏教は問題とする煩悩束縛になります
だから美しい公園があっても
美しい滝があっても 美しいというのは余計な単語ですけど
で 滝が悪くないんです
滝を見て なんて美しいと感動する私には欲が生まれているんです
だから滝 外に何のこともない
ただ流れている滝が 美しくもそうでもなく
汚くでもなく 単純な自然なんです
なんで我々はこの自然を一部綺麗と一部は汚いとか判断するんですかね
成り立たないで そんなのは
あの山が美しいとか どういう意味ですかね
それは ただ見えただけ
見えることに 山が悪くないんです
山が全然美しくないんです
ただ怖いだけ ちょっと間違ったらもうどうなるかわからないんですね
山を登ってみても 富士山はね
すごい綺麗やと言うんだけど
登ってみたら とんでもないんです
で  だから自然は耳に触れる
声は音は綺麗でもどうでもない
ただの声 音 これ受け取る私が
ああ なんて綺麗な声かとかね
感情を引き起こすんです
それでこの心に起こる感情が仏教は煩悩であると
山が煩悩 ではないんです
花は煩悩ではないんです
金銀宝石は煩悩じゃないんです
金銀は単純な金属以外何でもないんです
宝石は石以外何でもないんです
その宝石 宝石を見た人間の心に生まれる感情に
仏教が煩悩である 欲であると言うんです
だから外の世界の情報はカームワクトと言うんですね
欲を引き起こす もうただ対象
それで例えば蛇がいるとしましょう
蛇がいると 蛇は何もやってないんだけど
ある人はなんて可愛い蛇ちゃんですかと愛着が生まれて
もう一人 あー嫌だ 私は嫌いだ言って怒りの煩悩を作るでしょ
蛇が何にもやってないんですからね
蛇は何かガラスケースに入れてるだけ
それを見てどんな煩悩を作るのかということは
その人の個人的な問題なんです
そこをよく理解してください
この外の世界に悪口言ってはいけません
外の世界 悪いわけじゃないんです
いつでも問題は自分にあるんです
お嫁さんの性格が悪いんだから
自分の家庭生活は不幸になっているんだよと言うでしょうね
外に責任 ありえないんです
単純に自分が悪いだけなんです
はい ゾウ 犬 クマ 猫 カラス
人間などの生命に喜び
愛着 束縛を作る 色声香味触法はそれぞれ違います
ちょこっとした勉強にします
勉強しましょう 例えば同じものを見て
みんな喜ぶわけじゃないでしょ
例えば皆様 飼ってるワンちゃんと一緒にちょっとどこかへ出かけて
滝を見ましょう 自分が楽しいんだけど
ワンちゃんにとっては
めっちゃ面白くないでしょ
車で行ったならば 車に入って寝たいと思ってるんです
あるいは一緒に連れていくならば
じゃあ一緒に散歩をしようということで
喜んで散歩をするだけで
じゃあ試しにワンちゃんに見せてください
ほらほら 滝綺麗でしょうとかね
これでワンちゃんが喋ったら尾っぽ振るんだから
えらい勘違いするんですね
あ よくわかってるんだと
全然わかってないんです
ただ 自分に向かってなんかわけのわからないことを言ってるんだから
もう尾っぽ振ってるだけ
もっとよくわからない場合は犬は舐めるんです
で 顔を舐めるでしょ あれはさっぱりわかってないって意味なんです
だから犬にも舐められて生きてるんです
結局は はい このポイントはすごく大事なんです
カラスに欲を引き起こすものと人間に欲を引き起こすものはそれぞれ違います
しかし 全部色声香味触法
民宿なんです カラスがネズミを見て
まあすごい欲が出てきて
人間がもうステーキ見てまた欲が出てきてという感じになるんです
ヤギは草を見てよだれを垂らす
人間はごちそうを見て同じことをするんです
ヤギはごちそうを見たらよだれ垂らしませんね
草を見たらよだれを垂らします
もう止まれないんですね
もう大事に育てているもので
食っちゃいますからね
ダメダメって言って引いても引いても
もっとベロでも出して取って食べるんですよ
あの連中は これ大事な花だから食えないでくれと言っても食べちゃいます
しかし 私たちは手を振って作ったごちそうを見たら
別に全然興味ないんです
ということで 各生命に欲作るものっていうのはもう変わってきます
はい それでなんでこんな愛着
いわゆる欲が起こるんですか？体を維持して
苦しみを和らげて 心に刺激を与えるからです
また ちょっと論理っぽくなります
で 人間が草を食べてもおいしくはありません
欲が起きません 理由があります
人間の体壊れてるでしょ
だからこの体が受け入れる物質を入れなくちゃいけないんです
体が受け入れるチーズやカーフを入れなくちゃいけないんです
だから 茹でたジャガイモを入れるか
焼き魚を入れるか ご飯を入れるかでしょ
それで草を持ってきたっても
サツマイモを持ってきても
それは体に受け入れられません
だから苦しみはなくならないんです
お腹が空いた時は どこかの芝生に座って全部芝を取って食べてみてください
どうなるのかと お腹が壊すだけで
あんなのは消化もできません
もっとしっかり実験したければ
ゆかりの葉っぱとか食べてみる
口で噛んだだけで気持ち悪くなりますよ
ひどい味なんです もし飲み込んだら毒
毒になるんで 全くも消化できない
動物にもそれは消化できないんです
コアラ以外は それで この体に起きた苦しみがなくならないでしょ
それでゆかりの葉っぱの代わりにサラダの葉っぱを
茨城県産のものを食べたり
今ないんだからね で 食べたりすると
ああ 美味しいと という欲が生まれるんです
それでわかりますかね
この法則は なんで欲が起こるのかというと
体壊れると修復しなくちゃいけない
修復できる ぴったし合う部品は喜びを作るんです
合わない部品はもう欲は作りません
人間はアクセサリーに欲を抱く
ね いろいろアクセサリーね
高価なものありますからね
すごい欲欲出てきますね
見ただけで 心の感情を刺激するからです
なんとなく心に栄養を与えるんですよ
ネックレスやら指輪やら耳飾りやらね
これいろいろつけちゃうと
別に体には迷惑だけなんですよ
あんなのは肉体には迷惑でしょうし
病院に行くときはいっぱいアクセサリーつけて行かないでしょうに
治療できなくなっちゃいますね
しかし 病院で治療して出てきた途端
もういっぱい体に余計なものを塗ったりして
いろんな金属あれやこれやつけたり
プラスチック製品もつけたりするでしょうに
あれも栄養になるんです
結局は 壊れかけている心に刺激を与えてくれるんですね
犬はアクセスするのは全く無関心です
そこでこのダイヤは ５百万円だよと言っても
犬は全然もう 首にかけてあげても
人の周り遊んでくるとないんです
もう壊れちゃって 猫にかけてみてください
一生懸命手であれかいて
もういろんなことをやって壊すんです
こんなのいりませんと
したがって 欲から離れることはたやすいことではありません
それでまた大変なポイント
欲から離れましょうと言ってもね
うかつにそんなこと言うなよと
そんな簡単なことじゃないよと
これ 体に心に何か喜び
刺激を与えてくれるんだからね
刺激がないと壊れた体
そのまま放っておくと死にますから
そう簡単じゃないんです
はい 欲にもヤクザみたいなもんだから
人間不幸に陥りますから
まあヤクザですから 欲もたくさん種類もありますしね
その中で親分がいるんです
それは生存欲なんです
生存欲が欲の親分です
金が欲しいとかね ごちそうを食べたいとかね
旅行したいとか そんなのは子分たちなんです
映画見たいとかいう欲は子分です
それそれでも困りますけど
あの親分は生存欲です
原因によって現れる一切の現象は必ず壊れる
これはブッダの言葉ですからね
命も必ず死を迎える どうにもならんで
これは 体と心に必要な材料がなくなると
苦しみの感覚が起こる
体にも材料が必要し 心も材料が必要
続けるために これがなくなると苦しみが起きるんですね
苦しみが避けたい気持ちは死にたくない
死にたくはないという気持ちに変身するんです
私たちよく言うでしょ
死にたくはないと まあいい加減な言葉なんで
何回死んだことあるのかと
経験ありますかと聞いたらないでしょうね
だから経験もないのに
偉そうに死にたくはない
やばい やばい 怖い 怖いと
すごい現実的に恐怖感感じるんです
だから一つの理由は なんで死んだことも経験もないのに
死ぬのは怖いっていうのは
我々は無数に死んだ経験が溜まってるんです
心に 過去で限りない回数
あの嫌な思いをしたこと
溜まっているんです だから生まれたらもう死んだ人が生まれるんだからね
生まれた瞬間でもすごい恐怖感でいるんです
それは仏教的な見方で
現代人がそんなことは認めませんだからね
右も左にも区別できないんだけど
お釈迦様にものを言いつけてるんだからね
まあしょうがないんだけど
で 現代の人々から見れば
まあ経験ないはずなんです
なのに死ぬのは怖いって言うんですね
これがこの 物質なくなると強烈な苦しみが生まれるんです
それで私は発見した実験がありまして
やってみてください 息を吐き出して
まあ 1 分半ぐらい止めてみてください
どうなるのかと 息を吐き出して止めたということは
細胞に必要な酸素が与えていないということでしょう
死にはしませんよ  1 分半ぐらいでは
体の中に溜まっている酸素がありますからね
しかし ものすごい苦しくなるんです
あの苦しみが耐えがたいんです
それが我々を生かされているエネルギーなんです
苦しみが ですから 経験的に言えば苦しみを避けたいという
もう切望があるんです
何としてでも苦しみを避けたい
これがなんとなく死にたくはないという言葉になっちゃうんです
ですから これは仏教は生存欲ということにしているんです
同じことです 苦しみを避けることで生きているでしょ
どうしても苦しみを避けたい
避けたいなんですね だから避ける
避ける 避けるということをやっています
これは生きることなんです
ということは それが生存欲なんです
苦を避けたい 死を避けたい気持ちは生存欲です
それを元にして様々な欲や貪りが起こるんです
赤い色の服を着たいとかね
帽子も欲しいとかね で
高価な腕時計欲しいとかね
高価なカバンが欲しいとか
よくいろいろでしょ 水を飲みたいんだけど
フランス産のあまりまずいレビアンしか飲みませんとかね
で まずいっていうのは私の個人的な感覚
私はあまり飲みたくはないんです
であれ 香水ですからね
まずくてたまらん で まあそれは置いておいて
人々はいろいろ 欲は持ってますよ
自分のボートが欲しいとかね
ペントハウス作りたいとかね
そのようにいろんな欲が生まれますけど
あんな全部子分なんです
国会議員になりたいとかね
せっかく国会議員になったんだから
何かのもうちょこっと副大臣
なんとかとかね なりたいとかね
アホなことをいっぱいやってきてるんです
漫画集める人がいるし
で いろんなもうまた収集家がいてね
ガラクタ集めるでしょ？で
ビリなんかっていう何かおもちゃがありますね
そういうおもちゃ集める人がいるし
骨董品を集める人がいるし
芸術作品を集める人がいるし
欲もいろいろでしょ みんなゴミを集まって集めていますけどね
だから時々本当に生ゴミとか集める人もいますよ
捨てません ビニール袋に入れて家のどこかに置いておくという
これ全部欲なんです  セキュリティ会社頼んでいろいろセキュリティシステムつけてもらったりとかね
自分のお金は日本の銀行はちょっと信頼できんだからといって
どこかのスイス銀行に入れたりとかね
そうやって欲の世界を見るとむちゃくちゃいっぱいあります
詐欺師たちがいるし 人を騙す人はいるし
あの脅して商売する人がいるし
不倫する人もいるしね
こういう世間で見られる欲すべて欲の子分であって
親分は生存欲なんです
はい それで別なテーマに
お釈迦様がこの欲をまとめて
この一番たちの悪い欲
3つ見つけたんです なかなかたちが悪くて
もう抜けられないんです
例えば 子分の欲はね その都度その都度消えますよ
男性で美人には目がないと
どんな美人女の人を見ても追っかけていくとかね
欲でしょ あれは子分であって
戦慄然なんか壊れたら終わりです
そういうもんなんです
女性もものすごい服やらアクセサリーにね
ものすごい執着していますけど
おばあちゃんになったら何もつけないんですね
顔にクリームは塗らないんです
そのまんま もしかすると
そのまんまのおばちゃんのことは
孫たちがものすごく好きだから
それを似てる可能性もありますけど
唇紅塗ってるおばちゃんは嫌いです
可愛くないんです 何のことなく
そのままでいるおばあちゃんっていうのはすっごく大好きなんです
だって何でもできますから
そのおばあちゃんと一緒に
遊ぶことも ふざけることも
もう汚すことも何でもできます
それは別な話で やっぱりおしゃれしたい
おしゃれしたいと欲があっても
やがて年取ると子分だから
あの欲はね まあなんとか減ったりもしますが
生存欲だけは親分は亡くなりません
はい このたちの悪いもの
また ブッダの説法通りにいかないとちょっと難しいんですから
生きることは苦であり
無常なのです それはお釈迦様がおっしゃった真理第一なんです
生きることっていうのは
ろくなものではありませんと
生まれることも 年取ることも
病気になることも もうお腹が空くことも
仕事をすることも 全部苦しみでできているんだよと
希望は外れることも 期待していないものが起こることも
愛する人から離れることも
嫌な人と付き合うことも
あれやこれやとか まあ苦しみばっかしで
それだけじゃなくて 生きることっていうのは無常なんですね
そんな頑張ったんだからといって
ですから 生きることに
存在することに対して
愛着 執着を捨てた方が生きることを乗り越えるはずなのに
無常だからと苦だからといって
まあいいやと諦めちゃう
生きることについて 冷静になってしまう
すごいクールになってしまう
笑っちゃって なんだこりゃと
そういうふうに冷静にクールになったところで
生きることを乗り越えられるはずなんです
生きるとこのバカバカらしくてね
もうなんだこりゃという気分になったら
その気持ちは全くありません
その理由 欲なんです これ
たちの悪い欲なんですね
1カーマタンナ カーマタンナというのは五欲に対する渇愛
この場合は欲は渇愛という言葉に入れ替えちゃうんです
欲の言葉 パーリ語でたくさんありますよ
ローバ カーマ ラティ タンハ
ラーガ  あれやこれやとかね
結構長い ものすごいたくさんあります
で この場合は専門用語として渇愛という
いわゆる終わらないという意味なんですね
五欲は何ですかね？五欲っていうのはね
これ 一般日本語で言う五欲なんですね
見るもの 聞くもの 味わうもの
嗅ぐものと体で触るもの
これは欲しいでしょう
なかなかそこから離れないでしょ
いくらあっても足らないでしょ
これは刺激を与えてくれるんです
だからそれ 1 タチが悪いんです
これが  2番目 ババタンナ
ババタンナっていうのは存在欲なんですね
相当タチが悪いんです
3番目 ビバタンハ で 非存在を好む渇愛
これなかなか定義難しいんです
私たちは注釈書を頼って解説しますけど
どうも私は注釈書の解説は使わないんです
そのこの場合は  3は仏教の解脱ではなく
例えば非存在を好みますと思ったら
あんた悟りたいと思っているの？とかね
解脱したいと思ってるでしょ？違います
これ渇愛ですからね あの解脱ではなく
無になりたい 最近ある方が随分私長い時間喋りましたけど
なんかどうしても若い時から無になりたいと思っていたんだと
それでまあ私が教えた瞑想法も
あれもやって 結構頑張ってやってますけどね
私はもうあなたの瞑想法だけではなくて
いろいろ瞑想法でも無になれると思ってますよとか
えらい説教するんですね
相当このタチの悪い煩悩にやられているなと
この人は瞑想はするんですけど
能力もあるんだけど 知恵は成長しないだろうと思って
ちょっと時間なくなったんですけど
アドバイスすることはできなかったんです
無になりたい 無になりたいと思ったりとか頑張っちゃいます
何としてでも無になりたいと
なんだこりゃと だからそんなことでもない
それからあの死で全て終わりというね
現代思考 唯物主義思考
それも 3番目の欲なんです
あれ 強烈な欲があるんです
だからいろいろ心配することいっぱいあるでしょ
心配したくないんです
だからせっって死んじゃったら全部終わりだからと
科学的にと あんた科学的に知ってるのかと
死んじゃったらどうなるかっていうことは
科学的に証明できんでしょうに
何もないということも
何かあるっていうことも言えないはずでしょうに
だからなんかすごい科学者も結構いますよ
この唯物だけ 心は存在しないぞって言ってるね
それ考え自体も科学的
法論に逆らってます だから私は言うのは放っておきなさい
そんなのは証明もできないことだから
私は知ってるのは物質のことだけですと言ってくださいと
そうするとあんたは立派な科学者ですよと
はい そういう方々の欲がこの 3番目なんです
それからものすごい破壊欲持ってる人々いますね
破壊したくて破壊したくてもうたまらん
あれも生きていきたいんだから出てくるんです
天国で特製特等席というんですか
もらいますよと バージンは 12人か 23人かついてきますよというと
自爆テロをやります だから自爆テロをやりたくてやりたくて
かなり大勢の人々を巻き込まれて殺したくて
自分と他人を破壊する
あの破壊欲も結局は渇愛以外何ともないんです
ビンラディンのような人がいるとするならば
ものすごい破壊者でしょうに
アメリカの話正しければ
もう世界はみんな嘘を言っているんだから
誰が何言ってるかやっぱりわからないんです
で アメリカの話は正しければ
ビンラディンというのはものすごい破壊者なんですね
ただ 仏教的に見ると強烈な欲
病的になっている人になるんです
はい そこまで欲の説明でね
だから欲の説明は面白くするとまた欲が出てくるんだから
できるだけ面白くないように説明しているんです
治療して病気が悪化すると話にならないでしょ
だから今日その手段を取っているんです
ね 欠け欠かせないように見えても
長所よりも短所がありすぎです
仏教 欲は我々一般人から見れば
欲っていうのは本能であって
生きているものにはもう欠かせないものであるというふうに我々は思っているんですが
よく見ると 欲には長所は本当にわずかで
ほんのわずかで短所がありすぎ
だから割に合わないんです
欲は 例えば 10万円欲しければ 50 万分ぐらい仕事をしないと
例えば 3ヶ月間なんとかお金を貯めて
やっと 10万円になりましたと
使う時は あっという間に使って終わっちゃうでしょ
ということだから やっぱり割に合わないんですね
欲がない方が良い 生きるために欠かせないと思っても
生きるとは苦なのです
それが大事 事実であるならば
いわゆる生きることは苦ということは事実であるならば
私は事実だと思ってますけど
皆様は違うと思うならば調べてください
生きることは苦か楽かともし生きることは苦であるとするならば
よく苦しみ続けるために欠かせないんです
だって 生きるために欲が欠かせないでしょ
生きることは苦だったらどうします？苦を続けるために欠かせないものは欲なんです
しかし人は悩み苦しみ
好きですかね 期待しますかね
苦しみたい 苦しみたいと
不幸になりたいと誰が期待している人がいる
いないでしょう 幸福になりたい
楽しみたいと思って この世の品物に依存すると
憂い 悲しみ 悩み 怒り 嫉妬
競争 憎しみ 殺し合いなどが増えるだけです
こんなのは明らかです
私はちょこっと微妙にこの言ってないんだけど
この矛盾を言ってるんです
生きることは苦の原則なんですね
どうしても生きていきたいという人が勘違いしています
どうしても苦しみたいと言ってるんです
それでどうしても苦しみたいと思っているのに
苦しみが嫌だ 私は幸福になりたいんだとかね
神社仏閣をお参りして回るんですね
180箇所でしたっけ？ 108箇所ですね
幸福になりたくて まあ疲れるだけですけど
まあ運動にはいいかもしれませんし
四国の方々もいくらか収入が入って悪くはないんだけど
それ以外は何ともないと思います
で 幸福になりたいと必死なんですね
だったら生きることを諦めなさいでしょ
そこで矛盾見えますかね
だから人間は幸福にならないんです
仏道を歩まない限りは
で 幸福になりたいと思って欲を追っていくんですね
世の中の品物を追っかけていくんですね
金が欲しい 家が欲しい
土地が欲しい 立場が欲しい
権力が欲しい 人気が欲しいとかね
若く美しく体力があって欲しいとかね
こんなことを追っていくと
憂い 悲しみ 悩み 憎しみ
落ち込み 競争 戦い 争い
奪い合い 殺し合い 最後にみんな武器を持つことになります
お釈迦様パーリ語でダンダーダナ
サッターナ カラハ ヴィワダという全部書いてます
教えています いわゆる喧嘩
異論 争論 戦い 武器を持つこと
あれこれとかね だから日本の皆様方は結構金持っている
アメリカの富裕層の方々はどうですかね
いっぱい武器を持ってるでしょ
えらい幸福ですね もうボディーガードまで雇って
いっぱい武器を持って幸せにいるんですね
あれで なんて矛盾かというと
毎日24が怯えているんだから
この矛盾というのは基本的にいつでもあります
だから 欲がない方があんな恐ろしいこと何もないんです
ですから 欲も矛盾になります
欲の衝動で生きると 楽しみよりも苦しみの方が大きくなります
避けたい目的に向かって向かう生き方は矛盾です
避けたいことに向かって歩むならば
あの崖には落ちたくないと言って
まっしぐらに走っているならば
もう矛盾も馬鹿もいいところでしょうに
欲の衝動で生きてみて
不幸になると 苦しくなると
失敗すると さらに欲の感情が強くなるんです
だから金儲かりたい あれでこれでいい仕事を見つかりたい
仕事はできるだけ上手になりたい
それからなんて言いますか
どんどん上へ上へ上がりたいとかね
思って頑張ると結構大変ですよ
仕事はどんどん まあもう二
三年ごとにちょこちょこと格が上がるかもしれませんだけど
結構仕事自体も大変です
それでもし失敗するとまた大変なんです
我々の人生っていうのはそう簡単に成功しませんね
いろんなことに挑戦するんだけど
失敗するのはいつでもなんです
その中でたまたま成功する人生なんですね
現実的には そうなるとどうなるかというと
さらに欲が 失敗するとすごく悔しくて
もっと欲が強烈になるんです
そうするともっと強烈に頑張っちゃうんです
結果とすると さらに苦しみが増えるんです
怒りと同じく欲の悪循環が生じるんです
あの怒りが起きたら悪循環になりまして
どんどん増えていきます
同じく欲が生まれたら
欲も悪循環を作って どんどん欲を増やして増やしていきます
はい 次の あの なんでタンハーは渇愛と訳したのかと
この渇きに塩水ですね
欲は喉が渇いた人は塩水を飲むことに例えられます
これは一般的に仏教の例えで
私は別に新しくアイディアが浮かんだわけじゃないんです
飲めば飲むほど渇きが強くなって
結果として脱水状態で苦しむんです
欲にもいくらあっても足らない
悪くないという症状があるんです
ありますね 欲っていうのはいくらあっても足らないでしょ？もっと欲しいでしょ？お金はいくらあったら十分
アクセサリーはどれぐらいあったら十分
服は？決まりないでしょ
結局はいくらあっても足らないっていうことなんです
だから欲があった人は
例えば服に欲があった人は
服を買うことで欲消えません
かえって増えるんです
もっと面白いデザインないのかとかね
いろんな服を持った人は一回着たら次何を着ようか
どんなデザインにしようかとむちゃくちゃ悩むんです
皆さんはよかったね 金がなくて
金がある女性の立場になって考えてください
この有名人という人々とかね
毎回もう派手な普通の人は着たことがない
見たことがない おしゃれで出なくちゃあかんでしょ
あれって楽と思う？大変です
そういうことで 欲に対していろいろ追っていけばいくほど
欲が増えて増えて増えて増えていくんです
一般人がそういう喉が渇いたら塩水飲む道を歩んでいます
喉が渇いたら塩水飲むと
どんどん喉がどんどん乾いちゃって
体にある水分も水も取られちゃって
脱水状態になって死んでしまいます
何にしても程度ということがあります
が 欲の場合はリミットがなくなるんです
この世の中で何にも程度っていうことあるでしょ
たとえ我々にとって太陽が巨大な存在ですけど
太陽にも質量っていうものがあります
だからどれぐらい時間燃え続けるのかと
もう決まってます 永遠不滅に太陽が輝いてくれるわけじゃないんです
こんなものにも程度があるんだから
宇宙にしたっても このままじゃなくて
ある程度で行ってから破壊するんです
だから この巨大な宇宙にしても
太陽にしたっても 地球にしたっても
寿命にはリミットがありますよ
なのに心の欲だけにはリミットがないんです
いくらあっても足らないということが出てくるんです
欲は決して欲で満たせるものではありません
だから欲はなくすものです
満たせるものじゃないんです
欲を追うことは蜃気楼を追うことなのです
期待は叶いません 欲を追うともうひどい目に遭います
蜃気楼を追っても追っても水にはたどり着きません
砂漠です 死にます えーと
どこで休みますかね 奪い合いという
欲があると 世の中の品物を必要以上に習得しようとするんです
欲の渇きが入っちゃうと習得しますね
あれも欲しい これも欲しいと
しかし それは世の中の品物なんです
リミットがあるんです
それに刺激される他人も同じことをします
私がパクパクといろんなものは取ると
他の人を見て これやばい
俺もやらなくちゃってことやっちゃいます
それでどうなるのかと
世の中である人とない人が出てくるんです
このストーリーも一応経典に基づいて書いてますけど
欲張ってる人はいろんな品物を取ってやる
取ってやるとやっちゃうと
他の人 あ これやばい 俺たちなくなっちゃうのかで
俺も取ってやる もう一人
俺も取ってやると そうやってくると
社会である人とない人が出てくるんです
それから搾取現象が起こるんですね
あらゆる社会 社会問題
すべてここから始まるんです
管理することやら政府システムやら独裁政治やら
共産主義的な政治やら
いろんなこと出てくるわ
カースト制度とか宗教差別とか人種差別とか
何であろうとも欲が これが引き起こしているんです
怒りより欲がひどいんです
世の中の貧富の差は怒りで起きたわけじゃなくて
欲で欲で起きた起きたんです
世の中の戦争も基本的には欲なんですね
あのリビアのガダフィさんも権力は捨てたくないんですね
自分の家族のものやと思ってるんですね
ずっと国が 国の財産は
アッラーがそう言ったみたいんですね
すごいアッラーを信仰する人だから
人間はどうでもいいやと
それで自分の国民に向かって撃つ
それで今アメリカやらまたもう余計な戦争を起こしている
どちらにしたっても まず欲があって
それから戦争になっているんです
アメリカにしてもリビアの方が自分の仲間に入った方が一番いいんです
ものすごい石油がありますから
だから他人の財産にもうやっぱり
牙を刺したくなります
ガラアビさんがもう権力欲で何人殺すとでも私は大統領でいるそうということになるんです
だから世の中にある なんで生徒がたくさんなるんですかね
欲でしょ 権力取りたいんだから
戦うことに戦争することになる
奪えないようにと自分の財産を守る
守る羽目になる これで欲だけじゃないんです
財産が出てくると守らなくちゃいかないという危険性を感じなくてはいけない
不安を感じなくてはいけない
楽しみはなくなっちゃいますよ
他人の攻撃の的になる
だから貧乏の人の家に空き巣に入らないでしょ
だからセキュリティカメラいっぱい入れて
はい どうぞ来てくださいとちゃんと看板書いてます
こちらいっぱい金ありますよと
だから空き巣に入る人々もプロだから
そんなセキュリティなんかどうったことないんですからね
入る方法いろいろあります
窓を開ける必要ないでしょ
窓ガラスはカッターで切っちゃえばいいんだから
別に 窓を開けると あれもう警備会社からからね
もう 30 分経ったら飛んできますから
その間で盗んでいけばいいんだけど
もっと時間かかる 大きい家だったらね
時間かかっちゃうし まあそれからあの窓も大きいんだからね
金持ちの家の 貧乏な人の家の窓からは入れませんだからね
そんな無駄なこと 結局は豊かになるということは
攻撃の的になることでもあります
命を守るために得た財産は命を奪うことにもなる
だから命を守るために財産を得たんだけど
それであの命がなくなってしまうということはあります
それから心は汚染されるという
欲によって不安が生じる
欲があると不安 不安があるとさらに欲を作る
悩み 恐怖感 嫉妬 落ち込みなどが起こるんです
欲のせいで 欲の裏は怒りです
あの欲 欲と怒りっていうのは
あの同じコインの表と裏なんです
いつでも表は欲なんです
生まれると欲と一緒に生まれます
欲がうまくいかないと怒りになるんです
だから怒りについて語るのは簡単ですね
後から上がったものだから
欲について語ることは難しいんです
これは生まれる時もありますから
ですから欲がある人に怒りがない
私は怒れませんということは言えません
消えません すぐ上がるんで怒りが起こるんです
欲が叶わないと 欲しいものを他人他人に取られると
怒り 憎しみが起こるんです
欲があるとします 欲が叶わなくなっちゃう
失敗する あるいは自分が欲しいものは他の人は取ったりする
もう怒りが出てくるんです
だから欲があると怒りが出てくるんです
心は欲の妄想で荒波を立てるので
精神的な病気にも陥る
それからこの心の欲があるんですね
金が欲しいだけじゃないんです
頭の中で妄想で欲に絡んでいるんですね
欲はほとんど妄想なんです
だから食べるご飯はもう量を知ってるでしょうに
一人分はこれしか食べないんだと
しかし 食べたいという欲が頭にあるんです
だからあれも食いたい
これも食いたいという
10トンぐらいの品物を食いたくなってるんです
フランス料理も食べて
イタリア料理も食べたいし
同時に中華料理も食べたくなって
やっぱり韓国料理も美味しいと
全部揃っちゃったらもうもう 40 キロぐらい
でも食べるのはほんのわずかな量でしょうに
だから心の欲があまりにも無量なんです
それが妄想として回転すると自己破壊になるんです
頭がいかれて病院に行く羽目にもなります
欲の妄想も自己破壊的なものです
あれで はい それで一旦休憩にします
今の説明は 欲はなぜ悪いのかっていうところで
これからどうしますかっていうことはちょっと説明しますが
ちょっと はい それでは始まります
で 欲は本能で生まれつき付いているものやと言いましたので
まあどうにもならんでしょうということになりますけど
じゃあどうしますかっていうことをこれから説明します
生きるために 必要なもの
欠かせないものがあります
生きることっていうのは修復することだから
1必要なもの 欠かせないものがあります
生きる上で 2欲しいものもあります
この 2つよく理解してほしいんです
欠かせないもの 必要なもの
1に欲しいもの 現実的にこの区別をするんです
だから欲から解放する方法っていうのはそれほど難しくない
これやってみたらどうです
この区別してみましょう
欠かせないもの 欲しいもの
1の必要なものの場合は
程度量があること 必要なものはそれほど苦労しなくても手に入ること
どうしてもない場合は他人が与えてくれるものだとわかるんです
考えたことないでしょ
例えば 今 東京都の隅田川に値が飛んだ
あの世襲でしたっけ？放射線が入ったんですね
放射能が これで大人はどうでもいいんだけど
赤ちゃんのことはやっぱり心配でしょうに
赤ちゃんにはきれいな水は欠かせない
必要 手に入らないんですね
東京都は配っちゃいます
一応 これ 黙っていられないでしょうに
必要なものでしょう 欠かせないものでしょう
例えば 私がものすごく喉が渇いて
やっと店からミネラルウォーター1本買ったとしましょう
そうするとちょっと目に入ります
あれ お母ちゃんが赤ちゃん抱っこして
もう困ってるんだ 子供にも
私はさっとあげますよ
はい これ使ってくださいと
何の躊躇もなく 何も考えません
子供でしょ 赤ちゃんでしょ
もうこんな これに真っ直ぐでください
くださいと ということなんです
必要なものっていうのは
そんなに困らなくても手に入る
けるんです こんなに勢いで頑張らなくても
こんなにむちゃくちゃ頑張らなくてはもう生きていられないと思うならば
どうやってこの地球の動物たち
魚たち生活していますかね
動物で魚たちは必要なもののみなんですね
欠かせないもののみですよ
だからみんな何の計算もなく
何の金がかかることもなく
楽々にただで生きているんです
ただで生きているんです
鳥たちは巣を作るために 1円もかかったことがないんです
そういうわけで 必要なものっていうのは
人間だから一応金かかったりするかもしれませんだけど
そんな大胆に生きていられない
大変ということになりません
皆様にしたっても どんな人にしたっても
ものすごいわがままで
自分のことしか考えない人であっても
誰かが必要なものがないとわかったらすぐあげるんです
あげあげらしにいられないことですよ
人のことをまるっきり無関心でいる人も
自分でパクパクと食べることできないんですよ
誰かがものすごくお腹がすいていると
どうしても半分あきたくなるんです
ということは 生きるために必要なものっていうのは
いとも簡単に手に入るものなんです
必要なもののみを揃えることにすると
人生はとっても楽になります
だからお釈迦様が出家システムを作って
必要なもののみで生活しなさいと厳密に決めたんです
それで あなた方はずーっとこの世の中であなた方の組織は続きますよと
それで他の人々にも幸福を与えることはできますよと
だから 出家組織が人類に延々と影響を与えて幸福を与えたければ
いつでもこの根本で必要なもののみで限らなくちゃいけないんです
もしヴァティカンみたいな帝国作っちゃっちゃうと成り立ちません
だから恐ろしい金がある
カトリック教会よりも
何も持ってないお坊さんたちの影響力は強いんです
でお坊さんたち 今いっぱいものを持ってますけど
あの 持ってない場合はかなり精神的な力がアップになるんです
持たない場合は余計なこと
いらんこと に欲しいものになると
人それぞれ違います 必要なものといえばだいたいわかります
人間ならこれこれと 犬ならこれこれと
これ変わらないんです
ウサギ飼ったらウサギに必要なものとも決まっているでしょうに
猫を飼ったら猫に必要なものって決まっているでしょうに
じゃあ欲しいものになってくると
あなた何が欲しい？あなた何が欲しい？聞かなきゃわからないんです
ここから根本壊れていくんです
量が程度が成り立たないんです
欲しいものには量も程度も成り立たない
必要なものには量も程度もあるんです
例えば 地震で家が壊れた方々に住むところが必要なもので
その人にあなたがどんな家が欲しいと聞いちゃうと
私は部屋が 5つのある２階建ての車 3台の駐車できる駐車場もついて家が欲しいというと
どうしますかね これは誰もあげません
しかし 家が完全に壊れていると言ったら
行政であろうか ボランティアの方々であろうか
なんとか力を出し合って住むところを作ってあげる
その場合は ほんのちっぽけな 1部屋ではなくて
一般日本常識の標準に合わせて作ってあげる
それほどケチんぼの日本の政府も
あの あの 一応あの 今家作ってあげてるでしょ
あの仮なんて言ってますか
あれは 仮設住宅とか それは無料であげてるんです
なぜかというと必要だからなんです
それで税金かかったんだからって文句言いたい？言いたくないでしょ
一言葉も そんなもんなんです
例えば 日本の政府はここら辺で運動をやる
仮設住宅を作りますから
資金足りませんので それぞれ皆様がいくらか出してくださいと
出しますよ この力っていうのは
この生命の生き続ける業の力で
これはもう誰にもどうすることもできない
もし日本の政府は仏教的な思考でもあったならば
さっさと計算するんです
家がどれ何軒壊れましたかと
それで 1軒はどんな程度でお金で造ればいいかと
すっと発表するして 好きな人々も家 1軒とか 2軒とか
あるいは 10人合わせて 1軒とか
もうみんなでやりますよと言っちゃうと
さっとみんな出し合って
まあこれはもう 3ヶ月とか半年以内で全部出来上がっちゃいます
まあどん底貧乏な自分の国も津波で
あのインドネシアのね
あれでやられましたけど
まあ1年足らず全部作り直っちゃった
で 元の通りではなくて
元よりももうくっだらない
ちょっとしたハットで住んでいた人々も
もう家族もう8人とかね
それそれ大人になった人々に家を作ってあげて
夫婦にも別の家を作ってあげて
それはまとめに スリランカの基準でまとめまとめに生きていられる家を全部作ってあげたんです
ということは スリランカは金持ち
とんでもないんです 貧乏どん底でしたけど
それでも必要なものは揃うという法則なんです
欲しいものになってくると
そこで自分の国の場合はね
もう車も流された人がいるんですね
家だけではなくて その人は政府やらボランティアの訴えるんで
私の車も流れてしまったよと
家だけじゃないんだと
はい あなたに家 1軒と車買ってあげるとはないんです
家は作ってあげますけど
車のことは知ったことじゃないんです
それには何の援助をしません
そこで法則わかりますか？欲しいものになってくると
車 1台だけなんでやと 3
台あって何が悪いかっていうことになるんです
そういうことで 必要なものと欲しいものというはっきり区別しないと
頭がイかれて人生はどん底不幸に陥っちゃうんです
論理性 理性には関係ない感情です
欲しいものっていうのは論理性もないし
理性もないんです 単純な感情
ある女性は私はエルメスのカバン欲しいやと
もう一人は私はシャネルしか使いませんよと
まあ二人とも脳が抜かれたバカ以外何ともないんです
そんなのは ただの欲しいってことだけでしょう
たまに何が違うんですかね
かなり苦労しないと手に入らない
欲しいものにはものすごく苦労しないと手に入らないんです
必要なものはもう簡単に手に入ります
苦労しても手に入ること入るという保証もありません
苦労したんだから出て欲しいものは手に入る
その保証はないんです
苦労しないと手に入りませんし
苦労したんだからといって手に入る保証もないんです
例えば 一生懸命政治運動をやったんだからといって
選挙で勝てるという保証はないでしょうね
議員になりたいということを欲しいだけでしょうね
渇愛は増加する あのタチの悪い渇愛は
欲しいものによってどんどん増加していくんです
必要なものに閉じ込めておくと
渇愛は結構弱くなるんです
その他の煩悩も引き寄せる
この見栄とか嫉妬とか怒り
憎しみとかね 人と競争する気持ちとか
欲しいという感情から出てくるんです
必要というところからは出てこないんです
従って 必要か欲しいかと区別できることで
欲の制御ができるようになります
だから 欲が本能のように見えるかもしれませんだけど
これはコントロールできます
簡単に いとも簡単に 自分の欲の対象になるものは区別します
欲しいと必要と 欲しいものはできるだけ少なくするんです
できるだけ少なくするんです
いろいろ言い訳でもしていらないことにするんです
例えば 高価なカバンが欲しいなと
かっこいいと欲が出ても
私は最近結婚式に行く予定もないし
まあほとんどもう会社にばっかしで
まあそれから家にいるだけで
まあやっぱりいらないねとかね
そんなカバン持ってどこに行くんですかと
いうふうに理論でも使って欲しいものは削除するんです
はい 次のポイント この私のものという言葉は一つのフレーズなんです
これが並ならぬ苦しみを作るんです
欲の感情が自我の錯覚を応援します
欲があるとどんどん自我が強くなるんです
世の中のものが私のものということにします
世の中のものなんです
自然のものなんです 能って成り立たない
自然なんです 私のものじゃないんです
私のと入れた途端 並ならぬ苦しみなんです
例えば 皆様方はどこかの国で
無人島で 8メートルぐらいの津波が起きたと
それで島がもうハチャメチャになったと
痛くも痒くもないでしょ
私の何だらかんだらではないんだから
津波も地震も単純な自然でしょ
全然びっくりする必要もないし
当たり前の出来事 そんなのは誰にもどうすることもできない
しかし この津波にの変化が起こると
地震変化が起こると そこで私のというところが絡んでいるんですね
私の土地 私の家 私の家族
私の財産 私の会社とかね
これでどうですかね 気持ちは
そうそう 切する苦しみになるんです
たった一言葉 私のという
普通人は死ぬということはね
当たり前のことでしょう
死なない人は一人もいないでしょう
死ぬ人は今日死んでも明日死んだっても何の差もないんです
しかし この死ぬ人が私のまるまるだったらどうですかね
ものすごい悩み 苦しみが生まれてくるんです
例えば ある赤ちゃんが生まれる
ものすごい心臓には問題がある
その上 もう白血病もかかっていると
この調子ではこの調子では 1週間も持てないやと
それはみんな ああ なるほど
こんなひどい状態だったら
まあ治療は世の中にも存在しないし
まあ 1週間でしょう しかし
その赤ちゃんが私のだったらどうします？ものすごい
もう我慢できなくなって
苦しくなって 悲しくなって
いてもたってもいられなくなっちゃって
先生 何とかしろよとね
医者には何もできないのに
あんた方は医者だろうとかね
医者には変わりはありませんんだけど
遺伝がおかしいことは医者にはどうすることもできんだからね
そういうことになるんです
人がちょこっと走っていると
どこかに引っかかって
この服はバラッと破れちゃいますね
こちら見てニコッと笑って
あ 服が破れたと すごい冷静でしょ
それは自分の服だったら
こんな破れて あ どうしようかと
どうやって家に戻りますか？とかね
で 悩み苦しみが生まれてくるんです
だからお釈迦様 全部まとめたんです
もうすべての苦しみがたった一言葉で私のそれから生まれるんだと
だったら私のということは消せませんだから私とは何ぞやと客観的に調べてくださいと
そうすると これ幻覚だと見えてくるんだよと
それで心が落ち着いて
究極な幸福になりますという教えになるんです
家が壊れても 人が死んでも無関心でいられるが
私の家の場合は 私の家族の場合は冷静でいられません
激しい悲しみ 苦しみが攻撃するのです
という わけで あの この私のというところ
すごい大事に覚えておいてください
この一言葉でお釈迦様がすごいこの修行方法で解決してあげるんです
こんなちっちゃな言葉で
それから この欲ということはほとんど妄想的なんです
あの現実的 具体的ってわけじゃないんです
欲は現実的なものではありません
で 美味しいものを美味しいと感じることは
解脱者にも一般人にもできます
美味しいということはね
だからこれどんな時美味しいかというと
自分の体はその材料が受け入れられる場合は美味しいと感じるだけなんです
体に消化できない 受け入れられない場合は美味しいと感じないんです
で 私も体力ある時はもう脂あるものやら揚げ物とかね
これ結構美味しいなとか食べていたんだけど
今見るだけでも これってどこら辺美味しいかと
わからなくなっちゃったんです
それでも食べちゃうとあんまり美味しくないだけじゃなくて
胃がもたれて 2 日間苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
で そういう何も入ってない
もうただの生野菜とか
今すごく美味しく感じるんです
若者いる？生野菜 何が食べるのかい？とかね
サラダなんか口にも入れないでしょ？だからなんでこんな美味しいっていうこと変わるんですかね
体が受け入れられるかないかだけなんです
これ 体の能力の問題なんです
だからそれは悟っている人にもわかるし
悟っていない一般の方にもわかることなんです
思考で 妄想で 感情で 物事を欲しい欲しいということにさせるのです
そこで美味しいだけはもう大丈夫です
欲しい欲しいってなるでしょ
私はこういう食べ物を食べたい
こういう服を着たい こんなデザインのものを着たい
このデザイナーの服を着たい
このメーカーのものを身に着けたいとかね
あれはすべて妄想 頭で考えて
どんなデザイナーの服を着たっても
服には変わりありません
服の機能は同じなんです
体をちょっと守ってくれるだけ
デザイナーによって体を守る程度変わることないでしょう
あのデザインの服なら体は放射線からも守ってくれますよと
ありえないでしょ だから欲は妄想なんです
ある日 ある日ではなくて 2
日  3 日間研究しましたけど
日本ですごい人気のあるすごい値段
値札が高い いろいろおしゃれグッズって調べたんです
インターネットで写真を見ながらね
それはなんでこんなデザインは悪いし
ダサいしね こんな値段でこれは買うのかと
これはちょっとごっついとかね
これはあまりにもつまらないデザインやとかね
自分で買うつもりになって
そのシミュレーションで見るって研究するんです
それで見たっても物足らないんだから
実物を見に店にまで行ったんです
見て 自分が買うという前提でシミュレーションで見て
結局はこの 40 万のものじゃなくて
私が買うならばこれ 2万2000 の方がいいと
形もデザインも色も揃っているんだという結果になったんですね
で なんでそんな研究をしたかというと
実際そういう高価なものを使っている人々にとっては
あれがなければという大変なんです
あのブランドでなければとか
これが妄想なんです 私から見れば
そのブランドのものをあなた体が着たっても似合わないでしょうにと
あのブランド名もあるんだけど
デザインが最悪でしょう
だからあの 本当に妄想なんです
欲は 人から話を聞いて何か好きになるとか
私もこのブランドのことはいろんなことをどこで学んだんですかね
日本に来たんだからでしょ
こんなにアホな世界もあるんだよと
自分の国でならば もう自然の中でもう何のこともなくいたんですけど
品質はどうだい？とかね
これはどんなメーカーでしょうかとかね
を調べると いうことで
やっぱりこの情報が頭に入って
頭が妄想すると欲が生まれてくるんです
うん 妄想とは限りなく増やせるものです
妄想はいくらでもできるでしょうに
理性がなければ止まれないものです
妄想って一旦走り出したら
ノンストップで止まれないんです
止まれるブレーキが理性なんです
だから欲ある人にないのも理性なんです
妄想する人にないのも理性なんですね
欲もブレーキがないのに
もうエンジンもうどんどんもうトルクを上げるんですね
欲を抑えると現実的な人間として生きられる
それで欲という妄想が抑えれば抑えるほど
我々はすごい具体的に現実的に生きる人間になるんです
はい 次のポイントは節約
あの 節約は欲ではありません
小欲知足とは節約のことでもあります
仏教は節約よりは幅広い
いつでも完璧に物事を言うんだから
節約しなさいと言わないんです
小欲知足ということを言うんです
小欲っていうのは 欲しいものはカット
カット カット カットして
出家はギリギリ全部カットして必要で止まらなくちゃいけない
在家の人々はまあ全部なくても
まあカットしてできる範囲で小さくする
欲しいものもまあいくつかがあるんだけど
無量にはないということに
どこかで あ いいんじゃない？こんなところでという小欲なんですね
それからそれで満足する
ああ よかったと まあ十分やと
揃っていると この揃っていると満足しないと
この限りのない欲 渇愛
塩水飲むことになるんですね
だから 知足はもう欠かせない治療方法なんです
欠かせない薬なんです
だからお釈迦様が人間の心の病気には小欲知足という 2つの薬を処方してあげているんで
それで完治します しかし
俗世間では節約という言葉でしょ
あれは完璧じゃないんです
なぜならば いっぱいあるならば節約しなくていいんですね
物事を足らないという
時だけ節約してくださいと
今 電気を節約してくださいと必死で言ってるんですね
前は言わなかったんですね
しかし そこを言う前から
私は今住んでいるところに引っ越しして
最初にやったことは 高いお金で全部電気を変えちゃったんです
LED に一つ残らず 台所やらトイレやらお風呂やら全部
家にはそれなりに適切な建築家が決めた照明がありましたけど
全部ガタッパシから変えて変えていったんですね
それでもうかなり電力使う電力が少なくなるでしょ
で それが節約で それが意味があって
無駄にエネルギーは使わない
自分がどうしても必要なエネルギーだけ使いますよと
で それがまあ欲ではなくて
ケチでもなくて まあやっぱり自然の資源だから
私は一人の人間だから
余分に取らないというね
という考えです で じゃあそれでお金が残ったら
それで別な誰か助けてあげたりすることはできます
世間の資源は無駄に使用しないで
必要な程度の程度にすることは理性的なんです
ノーではなくて 任意にしてください
必要な程度にする 自分にあるんだからって使ってはいけません
いっぱい実っているんだから
全部取ってやると これは良くないんです
慈しみの実践にもなります
で 昔の人々は この畑やって収穫する時でも
自分に必要なものと交換するものを取って
一部はもう放っておくんです
そのまま なぜ？これは動物でも食べるでしょうと
鳥たちでも食べるでしょうと
これは慈しみの実践なんです
全部取ってやると 全部売って
もう無茶金儲けてやるぞというと
自然を壊しているんです
これは慈しみというのは反対なんですね
しかし 必要なものが揃っているにも関わらず
それを受容しないで 節約とはケチですね
あるのに使わないっていうのはね
とんでもないことです
逆に まあ結構 例えばお金の余裕もありまして
それだったらまあそれなりによりベターの生き方をしなくちゃいけないんですね
ケチっていうこともあります
だからケチはダメです
節約は正しい生き方なんです
ケチとは狂った欲なんですね
欲が狂っちゃうとケチになるんです
常識を外れた欲は 仏教は罪だとしています
で 欲は常識外れると罪ということになるんです
悪ということになります
だから生きる場合は欲が絡んでますよ
節約する時でも欲が絡んでいるし
ご飯食べる時も欲が絡んでいるし
これを罪ということには言えないんですね
困ったと 欲がいらんやというところで
しかしこれ 常識外れると罪ということになります
ですからケチは罪です
節約は良い行為です はい
まあもうそろそろ最後も終わりに近寄ってきまして
まあこのセクションは入れるか入れないか悩んでましたけど
まあこれ欲の一部なんですね
性欲っていうのはね それは別に勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
生命を個人として見る時は
性欲は余計なものなんです
例えば 生命は完璧な個人であると
言うと 別に性欲が別に余計なこと
また誰かの関わりを持つことだからね
遺伝子の中で子孫を作って育てることのみが
大事なプログラムになっているようです
なんかある この遺伝子のなんか本にあった話はパクっていますけど
あの 私の 私は科学者ではありませんだからね
遺伝子で全部からくりプログラム青写真書いてるんだと
プランがね そのように我々は生きているだけやと
そうなってくると 遺伝子の唯一の狙いは子孫を作ることだけなんです
自分が生き続けることだけなんです
我々はどうなってもいいんです
だから子孫を作る能力ある時期までいくらか大丈夫ですよ
病気になっても死なないし
早く治るし ご飯も消化できるし
そこで一回子孫を作って
それで終わりだったら
はい 死んでくださいと
それからざっと衰えていっちゃいますね
あの昆虫の中でね 一回交尾して死ぬ昆虫がいます
いますね 交尾したらもう死んだ
これでメスは卵を産んでもう死んじゃった
一回だけで死ななくちゃいけない
魚もそういう種類いろいろいるし
動物の中で猿とかね 犬猫とかもギリギリまで子供を産んだりしますからね
だからギリギリまで元気なんですね
犬とか猫とか おばあちゃんになっても子供を産むんです
で だからあの元気はやっぱり遺伝子は子孫を作れということだからねという話だそうです
ということは 我々の性欲って何なのかと
性欲はそれだけに限ったことにしても
遺伝子の奴隷みたいなものなんです
なんかやらされているような感じなんです
遺伝子が馬鹿にされてるんです
で なぜかというと 我々は性欲を実行して子供を作ったら
命にかけてその子供を育てるんですね
もう自分の存在価値がなくなっちゃったんです
もう何であっても子供優先
じゃあ作った子供はどんなことを？そいつらも同じことやっちゃいます
わがままでもう偉そうなことを親に迷惑をかけながら大きくなったけど
大きくなって自分が子供を作った途端
逆に自分の子供のために奴隷になってしまっちゃうんです
だから大きい幅でスパンで見ると
なんかバカバカらしいんですよ
自分が命かけて育てた子供が人類にとってはこの上の何かやってくれるならば
自分の命がなくなっても構わないし
ただのただの普通の人間なんですね
何のこともないんです
私はそこは欲がのこの呪いの
たちがね 自分にも食べ物がなくて
寝る所もなくて すごい苦労してるんだけど
交尾して子供を作るんですね
子供を作ったら ものすごい必死で勢いで凶暴になって育てるんです
野良犬は野良犬であって
別に凶暴ではないんです
人間には何も攻撃しませんし
しかし 子供が生まれると
もう牙を見せて近寄るなよと
すごいんです たまに餌をあげても
ちょっと遠いところで餌をあげて行かなくちゃいけないんです
何やってるのか 同じ野良犬を育てることだけでしょうに
自分の人生で考えなさいよと
自分が皮膚病で苦労して
人に石を投げられるわ
怒られるわ 追い出されるわ
食べる餌がないわ 他の仲間の犬たちに噛まれるわ
ひどい目に遭ってきているのに
なんでまた新たな三匹ぐらい同じ運命にさせるんですかね
そこは考えられないんです
犬だからではなくて 我々も同じなんです
我々大人ももうひどい目に遭ってきているのに
子供にはしっかり頑張りなさい
勉強しなさいと こちらは勉強しましたけど
全然役に立たないのに
しっかり仕事を見つけて仕事をしなさいと
こちらも仕事をしていますけど
やっと生きてるだけなんです
またいろんなことを言われるわ
馬鹿にされるわ 足を引っ張られるわ
もう仕事といったってむちゃくちゃ嫌な世界なんです
経験あるにも関わらず
子供を一生懸命応援するんです
わからないんです 子供に言わない
お前これから苦労するだよと
私に結構子供がついてくるのはそういうわけだ
全部本当のことを言うんです
なんのことになる 調子に乗るなよと
お前は勉強してもこんなものになりますよ
勉強しなかったら それでこんなもんになりますよと
そうすると子供たちってすごい冷静になっちゃうんですね
あのストレスがなくなっちゃうんです
だから ああ そうかい 勉強しなくちゃあかんねっていう感じで
なんとくとなる やっちゃいます
あ 喧嘩しちゃっても意味がないねとかね
だで大人しくなるんで
あるお母さんがね 自分の息子が私のところに来て
すごい大人しくいるんですね
すごいすごいかわいくて
遊んだり いろんなことやって
自分が来て子供見てびっくりするんですね
よくもこの子はこんな先生のところで落ち着いているもんだなとかね
どうやって管理しているんですかと
家ではもうむちゃくちゃやと
まだすごい小さいんですけど
私は何も言わなかったんですけどね
言えないんですよ 親が言わないことバンバン言いますからね
そういうことで この子孫を作ることには性行為は必要ですね
まあ当たり前のことですから
あの まあいいわ 余計なこと
で  しかし こんなすごいことじゃないんです
結局は子孫を作ることも
子孫を作る目的以外の性行為は
必ず心を汚すんです だから
子孫が作れる能力があるときは
もうなんとなく もうもう性行為してしまうだけで
それによって体が壊れることもないし
精神的に悩むこともないし
何のこともないんです
で その目的からずれたところから
いろんな無事で心が汚れるんですね
それ以外の行為は汚れた心の行為になるんです
遺伝子はもうもう協力してくれないんです
だから あまりにも性欲ある人は健康はもう壊れてしまいます
精神的な不安定になる
バランス崩して崩れてしまいます
しかし 子孫を作れる能力範囲でいる人々にとっては何のこともないんですね
また満たせないという症状もあります
性欲にも満たせないというね
足らないんです 解脱を目指すなら
心を成長させるさせて
サマーディを作りたいと思うなら
性欲は禁物です 誰かの奴隷になって自由にはなりません
たとえ遺伝子であっても
ですから 解脱を目指す人々には
性欲は断言禁止ということにしているんです
なぜならば性欲から束縛なんですね
性欲を行ったならば 子孫を育てなくちゃいけないんです
人を死なすわけにはいきませんよ
これはもう解脱と反対の道なんです
ですから それはもう束縛を作ってはいけません
性欲は瞑想でなくすものではありません
あの いつでも瞑想すればこれ治りますか？よくみんな軽々く怠け者で聞きますけどね
瞑想する前になくさなくちゃことはいっぱいあります
それから瞑想に来いと
性欲の場合は瞑想したんだからではなくて
瞑想する前に性欲を忘れてさようならと言って始めなくちゃいけないんです
道徳を守ること 自分を制御することで先に性欲を抑えるんです
だから出家すると 最初にもう戒律でこれこれこれ禁止という風になってくるんです
いえいえ 先生 私はこれから瞑想して
煩悩なくなくなってからそういうことはしないですからね
今放っておいてくださいという話になりません
瞑想して進むと 五欲に対する未練も沈んでしまうのです
それから心はサマーディ状態に達します
サマーディの順番があります
まず 性欲などなどはもうやめて瞑想始まるんです
性欲やめても五欲には未練があるんです
見るものに惹かれちゃうし
聞くものに惹かれちゃうんですね
それで瞑想すると 瞑想が面白くなってくるんですね
そうすると見るものは面倒くさい
聞くものは面倒くさい
煩わしいという気分になっちゃうんです
五欲は煩わしいと 五欲は煩わしいという経験が生まれたら
心はサマーディ世界に飛び出します
それが飛び出すパワーになります
だから順番を覚えてください
まず性欲は先にカットするんです
五欲は瞑想すると もう瞑想から喜びを感じると
五欲は煩わしいとで出てくるんです
ですから 余計なことで出家に対する性欲の戒め
性欲というより 性行為は
出家に断言禁止なのです
性欲なくせと言ったってもね
これはもう体のことだからね
もうこれはもうちょっと話にならない
だから性行為を断言禁止するんです
性欲を制御するために
七つのたとえで戒めてやります
お釈迦様 すごい怖い七つのたとえを使ってます
在家の邪な行為の戒律を守るためにも励みになるかもしれませんが
この教えは出家修行者のために説かれたものです
この七つのたとえは出家のためなんですね
真面目に返すって  54番目の経典を読むしかないんです
一人一人で そこで時間があったら説明する予定です
別な項目に入ります これは日本語訳できない場合は英語で書いちゃいます
リミテッドアビリティーズ
リミテッドリソース 能力は
何でか？リミテッドっていうのは有限
何でしたっけ？えっ？えっ
限定 限定 限界  リミットがあるということで
我々の能力にもリミットがあって
リソースとの資源ですね
そちらもリミットがある
人の能力にも資源にも限りがあります
これよく覚えてください
こんなのは欲を満たせるほどの資源も
強引に他人の分まで奪っても使用できる
かが体にも心にもありません
えっ？力が体にも心にもありません
あの心にもリミットがあって
例えば妄想して欲に落ち
もう溺れてしまいそうと思ってもリミットがあるんです
リミットを超えたら破壊しちゃうんです
体で遊んでやるぞと言ったっても
体にリミットがあります
リミットを超えたら死にます
それだけじゃなくて 世の中の資源にもリミットがあります
私たちは世の中のことを欲張って全部習得してもね
あれ あれ あらゆるもの使えないんです
欲に負けることは 人生という原子炉が制御不能状態になることです
ですから 欲に負けたらもう原子炉が制御不能になったということなんです
もう知ったことじゃないんです
例えば性欲にしても どんどん満たせないでしょ
どんどん出てきて どんどんやってしまうと
もう知ったことじゃないんです
結果は あるいは食欲にしたっても
こんな美味しいものは食えればもう何もいりませんよという状態になっちゃうと
これで食べて食べていくでしょうね
あまり長生きはしませんね
音楽もないですよ 若者は 24時間音楽を聞いてますけど
破壊されますよ 脳細胞は
リミットがあります 私は自分のリミットについても真面目に聞くならば
1曲と半分ぐらいです
これでもうクタクタ疲れます
あまり贅沢をすると体が壊れるように
あまりも心で欲を養うと精神的にイカれるんです
贅沢なことを知ってます
皆さんはね あまりにも贅沢しちゃうとね
体が衰えちゃいますね
退化します 進化しないで
頭で欲をあまりにもやっちゃうと
妄想で頭の場合は退化ですけど
イカれちゃいます 何者にも程度があるので
小欲知足なんです いつでもこれがもうゴールデンルールなんです
次別なポイント与えると損するかというね
一般的に言われることをですね
あげちゃったらなくなるんだよと
施しはよく謳われている
よく嫌われている 無視されている道徳の一つなんですね
施しということは結構いろんな宗教でも言ってるし
よくもう宗教がなくても言われていることで同時に嫌われているんですね
無視されるんですね 一神教で今日も施しを認めますが
その理由は見えないんです
一神教の方々も施ししなさいとよく言うんです
なんであと教えてないんです
理由はわからないんです
ブッダが解かれる解かれる施しとは
因果法則の一つの使用例なんです
お釈迦様は因果法則を発見したんですね
そこであの使用例 いろいろアプリケーションですね
一つのアプリケーションですよ
あの施しっていうのは
一つの使い方 取る引くエネルギーを与えると
向こう側にも取られない
引かれないように反発のエネルギーが生じるんです
これ 物理的なことで考えてください
何か取ろうとすると そのものも元に取れないようにしようとするんですね
だから何か取るということは
相手に取れないような反対のエネルギーを与えることになるんです
物質にも精神にもこの働きは似ています
これ 心も同じことなんです
取ろうとする 例えば財布から金を取ろうとすると
財布をきちっと閉めておくというね
取れないようにするというのは自然に出てくるんです
何かものを取る時 強い力が勝ちます
で 私はね 人のものを取ろうとすると
その人は取れないようにと力入れるんです
この競争社会 経済ってそんなもんでしょ
競争でね それでこちら商売して相手の金を取ろうとする
と 向こう側も何としてでも取れない
取られないようにしようと頑張るんですね
それで力強い人は勝つんです
品物を作っても その品物に取る力がない場合は売れないんです
同じ品物を別な会社が作って
そこに取る力が強力に入れると
こちらが買いたくないんだけど
向こうの力があまりにもありすぎちゃって買ってしまうんですね
みんなIPADを買ったような感じで
宣伝はひどい で 私も買いましたからね
で こんなすごいものあるのかい？と
いろいろ宣伝 あれこれ見ると
こんなすごい品物やと
むちゃこれ楽しくてびっくりやと思って買ってみたら
どうったことないんですけど
ね 私はこの年になって
そんなのはどうでもいいやという気分でいたんです
しかし 向こうの取る力が強くて
私は取られないというふうに思っていたんだけど
この 6万円はね やっぱり向こうの力が強くて取られちゃったんですね
だから 取る世界で必ずしも力強い人が勝つんです
持ち上げたい荷物は軽いなら持てるし
重いなら荷物の価値でしょ
その法則です ですから
取る引くとは力強い者が奪うことなんです
あまり優しい穏やかなことじゃないんです
それが  荷物の場合は相手は生命じゃないんだからね
どうったことないんだけど
重い荷物はもう取れない
重くて荷物の価値 軽い荷物はもう
られる 持てる で 私の勝ち
力強い人は勝ち これ 生命との関係になってくると
その穏やかじゃないんです
この法則を生命に当てはめると
弱い者がから強い者が奪って
弱い者の生きる権利を侵害することになります
私たちはそれをやってます
そんな優しい人間じゃないんです
いつでも弱い者から奪っているんです
例えばね 日本は大量に魚を獲っているでしょうに
食べてない ほとんど捨ててますからね
世界の人口と比較すると
日本はものすごい量を取っているんですね
あれ 力強いんだから取っているだけでしょ
技術はあるし 船もあるし
長い歴史の経験もあるし
だったらクジラから何一つもの小さな魚
何て言いますか オキアミです
オキアミまで食べないでしょ
あれ オキアミを食べる
シラ シラス シラウオ クジラからシラウオまで何でも取っちゃうんですね
これ 美しい道徳的な生き方じゃないでしょう
残酷です 欲の感情で行う行為に従って
罪 行為は従って罪 非道徳です
ですから 欲の感情で取ってやる
取ってやるでしょ それっていうのは
生命の生きる権利は奪ってやる
奪ってやることなんですね
これが罪です 各生命に生きる権利があるんです
それはもう犯すことはできま
犯すことはいけません
しかし 犯しています 与える行為が自分が恵まれる結果になることは因果法則です
そこで取るではなくて
お釈迦様が因果法則から与えることをやってみたらどうですかと
そうすると向こうは逆のことを取るということではなくて
なんとなくやっぱり申し訳ないって気分になってくるんですね
ただ 犬にでも餌を与えたら
犬が尾っぽ振ったりして
ニコニコと笑ったりして
楽しみを与えてくれるんですよ
お前 犬 尾っぽ振りなさいと振ってくれませんよ
取ることになると犬は遊んでくれません
だから我々は動物と仲良くしたければ
いつでも与える 与えることでやっているでしょうに
それで言葉通じない動物たちもエネルギーに負けます
で 負けてもうこちら言うことをやってくれます
そういうことで 我々は取るという欲ではなくて
与えるというエネルギーを作っちゃえばどうですかね
心にいきなり恵まれた環境が生まれるんです
周りからもういつでも恵まれた状態です
だって日本でよく無茶金持ちの人々がよく言う言葉があるでしょ
金っていうのは向こう
向こう側から寄ってくるんだと
自分で別に何の努力もしていないんです
ああいう人は過去生でいっぱいお布施をして
与えることをして生まれているんで
だからエネルギーがいっぱい溜まってるんです
だからなんとか冗談でなんとかやってもヒットして
もうバカ儲かっちゃうんです
本人が全然管理とか何もしないんですね
それはそれをする会社が必死になってやっちゃいます
そっちのも金がどんどんどん流れ込んでいるだけ
与えることで自分が恵まれるポテンシャルを蓄えるんです
恵まれるポテンシャルというエネルギーが蓄えられているんです
罪を犯すことなく幸福になります
だから取ると罪になっちゃいますから
与えると反対ですからね
与えたところでこちらは恵まれるポテンシャルを持ってるんだから
恵みが寄ってくるんでしょうに
だから何ともしてないんですね
何の罪も犯さず むちゃくちゃ豊かでいることはできます
与えるもの 与える人の気持ち
受ける側の必要性 受ける側の心の状態によってポテンシャルに差がつきます
これは仏教で長い長い長い話ですよ
だから 何が何を誰に どのような気持ちで与えれば徳になりますか
代価になりますか 消化になりますかどうかね
これ たくさんの話があります
まあとにかく欲しい 欲張って与えると消化になります
これから将来輪廻でいっぱいものをもらいましょうと言ってあげると
欲ですから ちょっと消化になりますね
やっぱり人を助けてあげなくちゃいけないと
必要なものを与えるものでしょうに
私には結構あるんでしょうにと
じゃあみんなもらってもらってというよね
一人で食べるよりはみんなで食べた方がもっと楽しいでしょうにと
いうことで与えると心が綺麗ですから
結果が高くなるんですね
そこで私たちは与えるものは
受ける側が本当にそれ必要としていると
そのなかったら死ぬでしょ
必要だから 欲しいからじゃないんです
だから欲しいものをあげるのは
自分の子供に 恋人にだけでしょう
あるいは奥さんに欲しいというものは
その人々にはあげます
ほかあげません 兄弟でも
お兄ちゃん 私はこれ欲しいんだから買ってくれよ
いい加減にしろよと 自分で買いなさいと言うんです
しかし 弟がこれが必要で困っているよと言ったって
なんでお前先に言わないのかと怒ってあげるんです
だから必要なものはやっぱり簡単に手に入るものです
それで私たちが与える時も
受ける側にはそれ必要なものだったら
与えることは対価になっちゃいますね
それから受ける側も悪人だったらまた消化になるんです
必要なものはもらって
命をつないで これから悪いことをするぞとなりますから
あげたものはいい結果ですよ
しかし まあちょっと対価ではなくて消化ということになります
そこで受ける側はすごい心清らかで
人類にとってすごい大きい
あの を 何といいますか
貢献している人々なら
その人を支えてあげることは人類を支えることになります
ただ ブッダに応じたことによって
人類が 2100年続けて助かったことになります
ですから 当時でお釈迦様にご飯ひとさじあげた人が想像できないほどの徳を積んじゃったんです
そのあげたご飯ひとさじで
お釈迦様は命をつないで
人類に教えを説いて サンガ組織を作って続くように設定しておいたんだから
人類を 罪はこれだ 善はこれだと区別できる能力を与えてくれたんだから
だからまあ そういうふうに
この受ける側の徳によっても対価になるとか
ものすごい詳しい説明があります
汚れた心で与えることも受けることも
結果は軽減しますね 汚れた心で与えることも受けることでも結果はあります
与えることは良い結果を出しますけど
あまり対価ということにならない
それから施しっていうのは
道徳の中でも基準一番基本です
幸福で豊かで長く輪廻転生したいと思うならば
施しでその資源を確保することです
無関心の話です で 解脱に達したくない
私たちはずっと生き続けたいと思うならば
資源を確保しなさいと
どこで生まれても幸福で豊かで生きていきたいと思うならば
施しを実践しなさいということになるんですよ
しかし 解脱を目指しているから施しはやめますは成り立ちません
例えば ある人は私は輪廻転生したくない
だからいっぱい施しをして恵まれたくはないとか
面倒くさいと だから施ししませんと
これは成り立たないんです
物に体に対する執着を捨てる
基本訓練もなく 完全に執着を捨てることはできません
だから解脱っていうのは執着してることでしょ
物に執着して解脱は話にならないんです
だから残念ですけど 解脱を目指す人も施しはやらなくちゃいけないんです
それで心には捨てる訓練が出てくるんです
解脱を目指す場合は 他の生命に役に立つならば
我が命でも惜しまないほど施しの気持ちが必要です
どちらかというと 解脱したい人がさらに一般人よりも施しを実践しなくちゃいけないので
それで心が煩悩からもうきれいになるんです
そうすると 例えばジャータカ物語
皆様いくつか読まれているでしょうし
菩薩の物語でどれほど施しを実践したかと
あれは恵まれるためではないんです
豊かになるためじゃないんです
執着捨てる訓練なんです
命まで差し上げたジャータカ物語があります
はい 今日はこれ最後のスライドになります
結局は理性で生きることです
最終結論は 欲っていうのは頭がちょっとおかしくなるだけなんです
お腹が空いたらご飯食べることは当たり前のことで
それに欲まで出すんだったら
欲の感情が生まれたら理性がないということなんです
仏教は他宗教のように
あれも禁止 これも禁止
ハランハランの教えではありません
ハランハランを知らないでしょ
あれ イスラム教の単語なんです
ハランとハラールという言葉 2つあるんです
ハランというのは禁止
禁止 禁止 禁止ですね ハラールというのは OK
OK  OK なんです イスラム教でハランというと
あるわ あるわあるわ むちゃくちゃ面倒くさいんです
欲は心の安らぎを奪う
悪を犯せ犯させる 不幸に陥れる
解脱の妨げになる現象だと説かれます
これぐらいはお釈迦様が言うんです
心の安らぎを奪います
悪を犯させます 犯したくないんだけど
欲が出てくるとやっちゃいます
それから不幸に陥れる
不幸になりたくないんだけど
欲が出てくるとなってしまいます
欲があると瞑想しても解脱に達せない
ならないんですね 迷惑です
だからといってお釈迦様はあれこれ禁止禁止はないんです
しかし 心の汚れをなくすようにと教えるのです
だからお釈迦様は心の汚れをなくしましょうと
例えば 他宗教で豚肉を食べたら地獄に落ちるんだと
それで体も心も汚れますよと
仏教にとってはどうったことはないんですね
豚肉を食べても ネズミの肉を食べても
もう死にかけているならば何でもいいでしょうにと
それで何を食うのかということによって心が汚れるということはあり得ません
だから食事制限とかね
食事の波乱とかはないんです
ただ 出家にはまあ一食二食にしてくださいと
夜はお腹が空いた方が頭が冴えてきますよと
智慧の世界だからという風には教えてありますけど
すごい自由で優しい教えなんです
理性的に物事を観察して生活すると
心が汚れないようにすることができるのです
理性的で生きてみれば
まあ成功します あ 終わった
はい これで今日の講演は終了なんですけど
どうしますか？まだ力が残っているならば
七つの例えの説明もできますけど
そうしますかね ６時  そうでしょ
一応時間的には５時半
あ ５時やん じゃあ一人一人で勉強することにします
はい そういうことで 今日のお話は終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
えっと 講演の時間過ぎておりますが
何か質問などある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手していただきましょう
あの少し短いんですけど
質疑応答の時間を取りたいと思いますので
あ じゃあ  今日はどうもありがとうございました
本当にですね 今日ちょうどお姿を拝見することができてですね
私自身すごく安心して心が晴れやかになったんですけども
今ちょっと震災とか原発の問題でいろんなことが言われてまして
また 外国人の方や外国人の聖職者の方がですね
国外に出てしまったり
または東京 関東を離れて大阪に行った方がいいというようなことが囁かれたりとか
ネットで読んだりしているとですね
私自身はどうでもいいかなと思う部分もあるんですけども
家族がいるとですね なかなかちょっと複雑な気持ちになって
気持ちが落ち着かない部分があったんですけども
こうして長老がですね
東京にいらっしゃるということが確信できただけでも非常に嬉しくてですね
質問ではないんですけども
長老だとも 比丘の方たちがいらっしゃるということで
本当に嬉しくてお礼を申し上げたくて席を立った次第でございます
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
私にもいっぱい無数に電話かけてきましたけどね
もう帰ってくださいと
私はこの人々を置いて逃げませんよと
で 今 日本の方々にもうすごい頑張れとね
何やと これという風に言ってあげるべき時ですから
まあ私はいますよと どんな不幸に陥っても
そんな気にしないとみんなに返事を出して
親戚に諦めていただきました
はい ご質問があったら
今日はどうもありがとうございました
物質に必要な必要不可欠なものと欲しいものがあることはわかるのですが
心にもそういう区別はありますか？ 心に
心に必要不可欠なものっていうのはありますか？ あります
というか もう心には邪魔なものっていうのは
欲 怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬でしょ
心を破壊するんですね
だから慈しみ 理性などは心
それから喜びは心を成長させるんですね
落ち着き 喜びなどは心を成長させるんですね
そういうところで 心にはいらんものと必要なものっていうのはあると理解した方がいいんです
欲しいものって 心にも欲しいものって心が欲しがるでしょ？体がじゃないんです
ですから それは欲などなどなんですね
欲と怒りでしょうね 怒りが生まれてくると
もうあれも欲しい これも欲しいになるんです
それ悪いことをね あれ潰してほしいとかね
殴っ殴りたいとかね それも欲しいという欲なんですね
心の場合はその 2つですね
あの煩悩が心を破壊する
しかし 心はそれが欲しいんです
我々は欲が欲しいんです
怒りたいんです 見栄張りたいんです
ふざけたいんです そこで心にはそれ欲しいだけで
心に必要なのは不可欠なのは集中力
これ嫌と思うんですね
集中力されたくないとかね
それから理性なんかは理性って何？と聞かれるでしょ
そこまでいらんと思ってるんですね
はい そういうふうに理解してください
わかりました ありがとうございます
すいません 今のお答えの中にもちょっとあったんですが
心悔の行参かだとですね
欲の関係はどのようになってるんでしょうか
あ あの行参からは善でも悪でもどちらでもですよ
ただ エネルギー意味ですからね
だから心が汚れていると悪いエネルギーで
心悔が不貪不瞋不痴だったら良いエネルギーなんです
ただのエネルギーって意味なんですね
ポテンシャルって意味なんですね
はい  他にいらっしゃいますか？どうも今日はありがとうございました
ちょっと基本的なことになってるんですが
あったんですけども 足足を知るというのも
ケチがケチはダメだという話があって
なんかお金を持ってる人はそれなりに使う方がいいという
なんかちょっとそこのケチと質素のところが理解ができなかった
うんうん そこはどういうふうに考えて
お金を持ってる人はどんどん使いなさい
やっぱりそこでもね 自分が贅沢ばっかりすることってよくないでしょ
だから自分が必要なものはね
まあ例えばもうラーメンではなくて
普通のレストランで食事一つ食べられる金があるのに
もうカップラーメン食べるっていうことは意味がないでしょう
で そこである程度で中道的で
まあ楽に生活はします
で 金残ったものはやっぱり人類のために使わなくちゃいけないんです
だから仏教はむちゃくちゃ金持ちになることに何も言わないんです
で すごい金持ちになる人は
仏教は指導して その余分に貯まった財産は
あの負けた方々のために
もうできるだけもう広げてくださいと
いうふうに そうなってくると
この金持ちの人がいてよかったと思うでしょ
みんな この人がこちらで工場を作って我々に仕事を与えているんだとかね
学校まで作ってくれたんだとかね
いうことで まあいくらでも広げることも可能なんですね
で あの所有的で すごい自分でエゴイストで金持つことはもうよくないんですね
だからあの高価な服買えるのに
あの セールで 100円の 1,000円のものを買って着るっていうことは
別に意味がないでしょ
電車で行けるお金あるのに歩いて行く
健康のためにだったらいいんだけど
それであの 200円儲かったというならば
貧乏な人はいいんです
もういっぱい金持っていて
これは恐ろしいでしょう
だったらいっぱい金ある人はみんなで電車で移行すると
どうぞどうぞ みんなでタクシーで行きましょうと
家まで私が払いますよというふうにした方が
自分に金あることは楽しいんです
自分には 1食しか食べられないんだけど
いっぱい金があるんですね
そうすると 友達4人呼んで
ものすごくその普段 その友達には高いものは食べられない
もう一緒に行きましょうよと
いて みんなと一緒に贅沢に食べると
自分もその金使っているし
より楽しみも得ているしね
そういう風にあのある程度で使うことはね
量を知って使うことは認めるんです
でなきゃケチやと ケチは罪なんです
まあそこら辺はまあ普通の常識でよろしいと思います
ありがとうございました
だから私もこのおしゃれにいろいろ文句言っておりますけど
決してやるなよと言ってないでしょ
ただちょっとからかってるだけで
もうできる人はやってもいいんです
ある女の子にある人はなんかとんでもないおしゃれしてゴートミ僧侶が出て
私を見たら そう あんた今日はやけにもうあれやこれで行ったんです
そしたら この女の子はなんで悪いんですかね
あのお化粧しておしゃれで
いえいえいえ 結構に結構ですから
思いっきりやってくださいと
まあそれだけ別にまあ断言禁止じゃなくて
程度知るだけのことなんですね
はい  あと一人ぐらいで
いらっしゃいます どうしよう
じゃあ待ってください
マイクを  どうもありがとうございました
今 人間心に必要なものっていう中で
喜びっていう言葉があったんですけれども
普段私たちが喜びっていうと
自分の欲を満たした時に嬉しいと思うのを喜びと思っていることが多いと思うんですが
欲とその関係ないっていうか
仏教的に一番いい喜びとされるものっていうのはどんな感情なんでしょうか
感情ではない  喜びっていうのは
例えばいいことをしたら喜ぶでしょ
例えば今日本が大変だから
なんか自分にできることをすると
なんとなくあっといういい気分になるでしょ
それって喜びなんですね
欲を満たすだけ満たすことでは
喜びというか なんかどこかで疲れちゃいますよ
だから充実感 自分が怠けないで着々と頑張るんだと
で 頑張った分はそれなりに結果があるんだと
で 失敗しても自分がそんなにめげませんとという風な
このところで喜びが生まれてくるんですね
例えばひどい目に遭っても
まあそんなことでめげませんよと
もう気にしないと思っちゃうと
なんかすごく自分なりに頑張って充実感が出てきますね
そういうものも喜びなんです
それから集中していると喜びが生まれてくる
自分が他人の役に立っていると喜びが出てくる
で 心に怒り 嫉妬 憎しみがなくなっていくと喜びが出てくる
で その喜びなんです それはすごい心に必要なんです
成長するために  じゃあすみません
人の役に 人の役に立ちたいっていう欲っていうのは
その何ていうか 否定しないで
どんどんこう 人に人の役に立ちたいという気持ちを欲かなと思う時があるんですけど
それは気にしないで行動してっていいっていうことと思っていいんでしょうか
うーん ちょっとわからなくなっちゃったんですけど
まあ人に役に立ちたいと思うだけではね
まあちょっと暗くなっちゃいますね
何もしないと だから役に立ちたい
立ちたいだけ思っていると
なんかそれ欲に変わってしまって暗くなる可能性もありますね
だから まあわずかなことでも
まあちょっとやってみるんですね
そうすると暗くならなくて
どんどん正しい喜びに変わってくるんです
時々いますね 人の役に立ちたいと思って妄想ばっかりするんですね
妄想することはダメなんです
これは喜びじゃないんです
だからまあ この程度ならできるんだからやりますと
いうところから始めれば
明るくなります はい そういうこと
はい それでは すみません
今日ちょっとまだ交通機関もかなり混乱しているようなので
これで終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして脱出が得られますように
サッビーティヨイワジャンツーサッブローゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーバワトワンタラーヨースケーディーガーユコーバヴァーバオトゥサッブマングラングラッカント
ゥサッブデヴァターサッブブンダヌバーヴェーナサッブダマーヌバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティーバヴァントゥテーアビワダナシーリスーニッチャンワンターパチャイノー
チャッターローダンマワッダンティーアーユワンノーสุขンバロン
はい 今日で終わりますか
皆さんも毎日いろいろ暗いニュースを聞いて
心を暗くしないで 明るく
被害を受けている方々にも
ものすごい元気と勇気を作れるつけるようにと頑張ってほしいと思います
できるだけ人々は精神的に応援することをしてあげてください
どんな物質的な苦しみも災害も
精神の力で何のことなく乗り越えることはとても簡単なので
今日本はすごい精神にいるいるべき時期だと思います
どうも頑張ってください
ありがとうございます